[Musique]
la science est reprise de l'ordre du
jour appelle la discussion de la
proposition de loi adoptée par
l'Assemblée nationale visant à protéger
le groupe Électricité de France d'un
démembrement dans la décision générale
la parole est d'abord à Monsieur Roland
Lescure ministre délégué chargé de
l'Industrie
madame madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs et les sénatrices notre vision
est claire pour EDF l'énergie d'ici un
nationale est au cœur de la transition
énergétique du pays c'est aussi la
vision qui régnait il y a près de 77 ans
quand Marcel Paul un ministre communiste
a présidé la création d'EDF
avec comme objectif un monopole de
l'énergéticien qui a conduit 77 ans plus
tard à l'électrification du pays à la
construction du deuxième parc nucléaire
au monde nous en voyons nous en
bénéficions encore des fruits
aujourd'hui avec un mix électrique parmi
les moins émetteurs de gaz à effet de
serre au monde et parmi les plus
compétitifs
depuis 20 ans évidemment notre
énergéticien national a été affectée
pour du bon et du moins bon par
l'ouverture sur l'Union européenne avec
la loi de février 2000 sur la
modernisation du service public de
l'électricité et le sommet de Barcelone
en mars 2002 qui a conduit la
libéralisation du marché de
l'électricité et du gaz
certes le marché intégré à des défauts
et nous y travaillons reconnaissons
quand même tous ensemble que ce marché
est aujourd'hui le plus gros système
intégré en électricité du monde qui fait
quasiment tous les jours que quand la
France a besoin d'électricité elle peut
en importer de ses voisins et
inversement quand elle en a trop elle
peut elle-même en exporter ailleurs
ayant vécu une dizaine d'années au
Québec qui depuis deux jours à 1 million
de Québécois privé d'électricité je sais
de quoi je parle et je vois combien
cette capacité de l'Europe à avoir un
marché de l'électricité intégrée nous a
été favorable notre vision pour EDF est
clair le groupe Électricité de France
est et restera un instrument essentiel
pour mettre en œuvre la politique
énergétique de l'État français et
au-delà un champion à l'exportation
aujourd'hui et ça a été extrêmement bien
spécifié dans la lettre de mission du
nouveau PDG l'ucrément dont vous avez
collectivement voter la nomination à ce
titre le sujet d'EDF c'est
essentiellement la production les
capacités opérationnelles et la conduite
des grands projets industriels EDF a
besoin d'investir des dizaines de
millions de dizaines de milliards
d'euros pardon tous les ans pour
lesquels il faut des moyens et
l'incrédibilité financière EDF a besoin
de retrouver sa maîtrise industrielle
dans le nucléaire EDF a besoin de monter
sur les énergies renouvelables avec des
objectifs ambitieux pour les 30
prochaines années
pour cela le gouvernement a pris ses
responsabilités l'État a toujours
accompagné EDF dans ses opérations de
recapitalisation que ce soit en 2017 ou
2022 on n'a jamais autant investi dans
le nucléaire que depuis 2017 on va
évidemment accélérer tout ça mais il
faut quand même le reconnaître nous
avons sécurisé le calendrier de l'EPR 2
avec le projet de loi nucléaire que vous
avez voté en première lecture
EDF aujourd'hui est néanmoins une
société endettée une société avec de
gros besoins d'investissement c'est donc
conformément aux engagements pris par le
Président de la République durant sa
campagne que nous avons lancé dès cet
été une offre publique d'achat pour
prendre le contrôle à 100% du capital
d'EDF vous avez libéré 9,7 milliards de
crédits budgétaires avec cette
nationalisation nous renforçons les
moyens d'ef pour investir dans les
prochaines années et nous crédibilisons
son sérieux financier
vous le savez l'offre publique d'achat
est en cours de finalisation d'ici début
juin après épuisement des derniers
recours
ce gourvetement répond donc au vrai
problématique du groupe EDF et nous
avons été il faut le reconnaître un peu
surpris quand cette proposition de loi
visant à nationaliser EDF est tombé dans
un calendrier un peu surprenant et il
faut le reconnaître dans de l'examen à
l'Assemblée nationale flirtant parfois
avec des théories du complot cette PPL
vise à répondre à des angoisses qui
n'ont aucun lieu d'être Bruno Le Maire a
eu l'occasion de le dire à plusieurs
reprises je les dis moi-même devant la
tribune de l'Assemblée nationale et je
vous le répète le projet Hercule est
mort et enterré il n'y a aucun projet ni
visible ni caché de démantèlement de
notre opérateur national
je salue le travail sénatorial qui
durant l'examen en commission a fait
preuve de sagesse en réécrivant une
bonne part du texte issue de l'Assemblée
nationale je salue particulièrement le
travail et l'esprit de responsabilité du
rapporteur pour cette remise à plat en
particulier le texte de la commission
supprime les articles 1 et 3 de
nationalisation du groupe EDF qui
pouvait fragiliser l'OPA en cours de
finalisation tout en arrivant reconnant
sur le à contretemps retire de l'article
2 les références aux activités d'un
groupe unifié dans le capital aurait été
totalement accessible qui rendait du
coup absolument impossible les
opérations courantes de gestion d'actifs
par EDF dont les trois milliards de
sessions d'actifs dans lequel
l'électricité l'électricien pardon
national et d'ores et déjà engagé
ce texte issue de la Commission modifie
également l'article 3 bis pour
restreindre le périmètre d'extension des
tarifs réglementés de vente au champ des
TPE qui ne sont pas encore éligibles sur
cette base nous avons donc matière avoir
une discussion je dirais apaiser et
constructive il nous reste malgré tout
deux points de désaccord sur lesquels je
souhaite attirer votre attention on y
reviendra évidemment dans le cadre de la
discussion des amendements d'une part
sur l'article 2 cet article inscrit dans
la loi que les tiens détient 100% du
capital d'EDF pas de problème avec ça
nous partageons cette proposition qui
redonne une place importante au
Parlement qui aurait ainsi à se
prononcer sur n'importe quel réouverture
du capital
il n'y a aucune ambiguïté sur nos
intentions je le répète le projet
Hercule a été abandonné mais ça va sans
dire ça va peut-être mieux en l'écrivant
en revanche tel qu'il est formulé
aujourd'hui cet article prescrit
l'ouverture d'au moins 1,5% du capital
d'EDF aux salariés et anciens salariés
du groupe et ceux d'ici le premier
janvier 2024 je l'ai dit au père n'est
pas encore terminé nous reste notamment
à convaincre suite au recours encore
déposé à peu près 5% des actionnaires à
apporter leur titre dont un certain
nombre d'actionnaires salariés il nous
semblerait pour le moins prématuré
d'envisager de l'intéressement les
participations via de l'actionnaire et
salarié pour quelques mois alors que
nous viendrions d'acheter les 10 actions
de la part des salariés en question la
situation financière d'EDF il faut être
clair ne le permet pas aujourd'hui nous
proposons dans le cadre de la discussion
un amendement de compromis qui vise à
laisser ouverte la possibilité
d'actionnariat salarié pour l'avenir
tout en évitant de la forcer en la
rendant automatique et ce dès le premier
janvier prochain deuxième point de
discussion et j'en terminerai là vous
avez proposé l'extension du tarif
déréglementé du trve à toutes les TPE
alors qu'aujourd'hui il est réservé au
TPE petite consommatrice c'est peut-être
bien mais ça coûte cher monsieur le
Président gay d'abord il faut
reconnaître que ça remet en profondeur
en question la logique même du TRV qui
dans le cadre des discussions avec la
Commission européenne qui ont permis de
l'adopter visaient avant tout à protéger
les consommateurs ça veut dire comme
vous et moi et les petites entreprises
qui avaient elles-mêmes une consommation
similaire au ménage à être protégé par
ce tarif réglementé le discussion avec
la commission visa à ce que toutes les
entreprises qui ont une consommation je
dirais plus proche d'une consommation
industrielle soit elle au tarif de
marché la rédaction que vous avez
proposé est mieux rédiger elle limite le
champ au TPE elle pour autant elle
mettra en place une discussion complexe
qui prendrait beaucoup beaucoup de temps
avec la Commission de régulation
d'électricité avec la Commission
européenne qui prendrait sans doute bien
bien plus longtemps que nécessaire alors
qu'aujourd'hui notre objectif premier il
est de protéger les TPE les PME les et
les grandes entreprises contre la crise
énergétique ça ne serait pas plus long
puisqu'on aura l'occasion de discuter
tout ça dans le cadre de la discussion
pour conclure vous rappelez juste que
nous sommes évidemment en phase avec les
objectifs réaffirmés par cette PPL
réécrite par nos soins avoir un
opérateur national de qualité inscrit
dans la durée qui pourra investir tout
ce qu'il faudra pour que les 77 ans qui
s'ouvrent soit aussi remplis de succès
que les 77 ans qui viennent de s'écouler
merci à tous et à toutes
merci la parole est maintenant rapportée
en Gérard longuerre apporteur de la
commission des finances
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
nous examinons dans l'enthousiasme
générale une PPE qui a été votée à
l'unanimité ou presque à l'Assemblée
nationale cette TPE présentée par
l'excellent député de l'heure Philippe
Brun ancien députant ancienne
circonscription de Pierre Mendès France
a été voté à la quasi inanimité ce qui
cache un profond malentendu dans les
intentions des différents députés qui se
sont exprimés à cette occasion
trois points dans ce texte de loi qui
nous vient de l'assemblée et pour lequel
la commission des finances au nom de
laquelle je rapporte a tenu à apporter
des modifications substantielles le
premier concerne Mayotte qui apparaît
mystérieusement bon on en a rapport sur
l'électricité de Mayotte qui appartient
pour partie au département pour partie à
EDF soit ce n'est pas l'habitude de
notre Assemblée d'accepter des rapports
mais il aurait été impossible de
trancher sur le fond dans les délais
d'études qui étaient donnés à notre
commission des finances le deuxième
point beaucoup plus important et qui
explique en grande partie qui explique
presque totalement le vote du groupe
auquel j'appartiens du groupe politique
auquel j'appartiens ici au Sénat et qui
a été le vote des lerres de l'Assemblée
c'est en effet le soutien apporté aux
entreprises la commission des finances a
estimé que nous pouvions faire sauter le
verrou du
transformateur de 36 kVA qui le Voltaire
pourquoi parce qu'il divisait
inutilement la condition des artisans
qui pour les uns bénéficieraient du
bouclier fiscal pour la raison qu'il
serait en dessous et pour les autres
exerçant à peu près le même métier et
étant dans les normes de le de la
définition des TPE par l'Union
européenne ne pourrait pas en bénéficier
donc dès lors qu'on a moins de 10
salariés et moins de 2 millions de
chiffre d'affaires et quel que soit la
capacité de transformateur nous pourrons
ils pourrons bénéficier du bouclier
tarifaire trve aller plus loin on
viendra dans le débat des amendements
aurait été impossible et dangereux
juridiquement
tant vis-à-vis des sociétés qui délivre
de l'électricité que vis-à-vis de
l'Union européenne alors le troisième
point est beaucoup plus important il est
passionnant même c'est la crainte
exprimée avec force par l’auteur de la
PPL sur le risque de démembrement de DF
et là je crois il faut remercier
monsieur Brun parce que avec sa PPL il
nous oblige à réfléchir monsieur le
ministre chers collègue sur le marché de
l'électricité tel qu'il vient d'être
secoué depuis un peu plus d'un an et tel
qu'il peut évoluer dans l'avenir et
c'est ce marché de l'électricité
européen
qui doit donner aux dirigeants de DF je
dirais des indications sur les libertés
dont ils doivent jouir pour diriger leur
entreprise une plus grande respect pour
Marcel Paul et pour des raisons
personnelles en plus mais nous ne sommes
plus en 1946 le marché de l'énergie
électrique et libre pour la production
ce qui n'était pas le cas jusqu'en 2002
et il est libre pour la vente aux
consommateurs qu'ils soient d'ailleurs
petit ou grands que l'on produise ou non
de l'électricité et personne en Europe
me songent à remettre en cause cette
liberté cette liberté et ce marché
ont-ils été catastrophique la réponse
est non en réalité entre
2015 et 2020 le prix moyen du spot s'est
situé entre 35 rôles mégawatts et 40
euros le mégawatts
au point d'ailleurs c'est une anecdote
que la reine à 43 a été moins sollicitée
ou pas sollicité du tout pendant cette
période
je reviendrai sur la reine
nous avons donc un marché qui est libre
mais il y a de vraies questions qui ne
sont pas tranchées et qui relève c'est
le Ministre des négociations
intergouvernementales et ensuite du
Parlement européen d'une part confirmer
la liberté à laquelle sont attachées
l'immense majorité des Européens sur la
production et la distribution et la
vente d'électricité je dis bien la vente
d'électricité
et puis se poser la question Quels sont
les priorités de ce marché électrique
faut-il décarboner la société ou faut-il
la verdir pas tout à fait la même chose
si on décarbonne on s'appuie sur le
nucléaire si l'on s'agit simplement de
la verdir malheureux nucléaire se
retrouve confronté au même difficulté de
financement qui l'handicap aujourd'hui
nous avons un deuxième sujet majeur à
l'aune de l'expérience la tragique
expérience russe fin du conflit pas du
conflit de l'invasion de la l'Ukraine
par la Russie
quel est le souci d'indépendance
acceptons-nous de placer l'indépendance
énergétique au rang qui doit être le
sien c'est à dire une principale
préoccupation celle qui avait d'ailleurs
inspiré
Georges Pompidou et Pierre Messmer
lorsqu'ils ont présenté en mars
1974 un mois avant disparition de
président Pompidou le programme
énergique le programme nucléaire
français sur lequel nous vivons encore
dans la lancée
donc question verdir ou décarbonée
question indépendante ou prit
occasionnel le meilleur marché ce qui a
été longtemps le gaz russe il faut le
reconnaître mais c'est aujourd'hui
frapper d'incertitude j'ajoute
peut-on imaginer un organisation du
marché qui dépend de moins du spot et
donc du coup marginal de la dernière
entreprise de production électrique
thermique en général allemand de
marchand de la limite est-ce qu'on ne
peut pas avoir des systèmes différents
car le marché de l'électricité bute sur
un problème que connaissent bien nos
amis électriciens c'est que
l'électricité ne se stocke pas et donc
la régulation est à peu près impossible
et les écarts de prix sont
spectaculaires ce qui aboutit quand on a
un marché qui fonctionne essentiellement
sur le coup marginal à des écarts de
prix qui sont à peu près insupportables
pour le consommateur j'ajoute que nous
sommes français fiers de notre
réalisation nucléaire on aimerait en
profiter un petit peu et de ne pas être
entraîné à la hausse par des cette
opération du coup marginal donc
ces questions sur le marché sont
absolument préalables elle pèse déjà sur
le statut et c'est là où je m'adresse
non pas je m'adresse à vous mais au-delà
du Sénat à l'auteur de la PPL le
démembrement
d'EDF il existe en partie le transport
et la distribution pourquoi parce que
nous avons l'obligation au nom de cette
liberté
d'accepter l'accès des tirs au réseau et
comme il y a des monopoles techniques je
ne parle pas de monopole économique je
parle vrai de monopole technique il est
impensable de multiplier les réseaux
tant de transport que des distribution
il faut donc bien accepter que
RTE et enedis quoique propriété de la
puissance publique ou de d'EDF pour RTE
puisse
être indépendant d'un défaut d'un des
utilisateurs des réseaux mais qui n'est
que aujourd'hui l'un des utilisateurs de
réseau
cette première différence vaut aussi
pour la question que j'évoquais à
l'instant qui est la question de la
reine parce que la Réunion c'est ça se
termine en 2025 nous sommes à la fin de
la reine et qu'est-ce qui va se passer
on s'appelle faut-il maintenir ce
système faut-il se contenter d'augmenter
le prix faut-il imaginer ce qui serait
peut-être intelligent un système tech
orteil c'est-à-dire ou bien vous prenez
ou bien vous payer une certaine somme je
suis quelqu'un des assurances après tout
l'assurance parraîchère qu'avant
l'accident on la paye tout le temps même
quand on n'a pas d'accident et quand on
a un accident on est content d'être
assuré la reine a joué ce rôle
d'assurance sauf que c'est une assurance
qu'on paye après l'accident ce qui est
évidemment beaucoup plus facile c'est
comme gagner sur les courses de chevaux
après l'arrivée et bien
système là de la reine est au cœur des
préoccupations de même nous avons des
fournisseurs extrêmement sérieux y
compris français d'électricité qui
accepteraient volontiers de participer
au financement du nucléaire français
n'ont pas pour l'exploiter Dieu les en
garde enfin Dieu ou la SN ou l'URSS je
ne sais pas mais en tous les cas ils ne
souhaitent pas exploiter il souhaite
simplement financer pour avoir des
droits de tirage avec une certaine
stabilité on pourrait même imaginer nous
législateur après tout ça enlève de
notre rôle de conduire les
fournisseur les entreprises qui
revendiquent de fournir de l'électricité
de garantir 70% de l'approvisionnement
par des contrats à long terme que la
Commission jusqu'à présent refuse et
donc je me dis vous avez un formidable
combat mais c'est quand on verra les
éléments de ce combat les points gagnés
les points hauts contrôlés et puis les
malheureusement les embuscades dans
telle ou telle règlement que nous
pourrons nous retourner vers les
dirigeants d'EDF en leur disant
attention là vous avez une opportunité
qu'il ne faut saisir ou au contraire
vous avez un risque qu'il faut assumer
et c'est la raison pour laquelle je me
retourne vers vous d'abord mais vers
Philippe Brun également en les exigeant
votre PPL elle est elle sera parfaite
quand on connaîtra quand on connaîtra
les règles du jeu définitif aujourd'hui
et les prématurés et donc je propose une
mesure conservatoire 100% du capital
l'État à la main le Parlement est en
pleine responsabilité et laissant à
chacun faire entier ayant confiance en
nos électriciens et c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous avons accepté et c'est
terminé de faire d'EDF une une fierté
nationale c'est dans le texte
en fait
vous savez que nous sommes dans des
niches que le temps est contraint donc
je demanderai à chacun des orateurs par
respect pour les porteurs de ses
propositions de doigts de respecter leur
temps de parole de façon à ce que l'on
puisse finir les deux PPL merci
monsieur bien que vous avez la parole
mon démocratique sociale européen
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur mais
chers collègues alors que le doute plane
sur l'avenir du groupe EDF et malgré
l'abandon des projets Hercule les
députés ont voté la proposition de loi
visant à la nationalisation du groupe
EDF
mais au Sénat il a été rebaptisé protégé
le groupe Électricité de France donne
démembrement
le spectre d'excuse ne s'est pas
totalement dissiper et nourrit des
inquiétudes il vivait à réorganiser des
F pour subvenir aux investissements
nécessaires d'une part pour prolonger la
théorie de vie du port nucléaire d'autre
part développer les énergies
renouvelables sans oublier le père il
faisait à créer trois entités la
première regroupant nucléaire et réseaux
de transport la deuxième associée en
commercial et réouvrable la troisième
incluelle des barrages hydroélectriques
avec un risque c'est de vendre par
appartement les branches les plus
rentables du premier opérateur européen
d'électricité
sur la formule consacrée
socialisor les pertes et privatisons les
profits
on comprend mieux les craintes des
auteurs du texte
nul doute que nous allons connaître quoi
qu'on en dise une croissance
esponancielle du prix et de la
consommation de l'électricité au rythme
du développement d'activités très
énergivore comme celle du numérique
avait sa courte de serveur informatique
ou encore du choix d'un business model
un industriel du toute électrique pour
les véhicules automobiles dans ce
contexte aggravé par une géopolitique
européenne internationale
en crise nous devons déterminer nos
orientations avec la plus grande
prudence l'État doit garder la maîtrise
des infrastructures stratégiques qui
sont la production et la distribution
d'électricité
garantissant l'indépendance énergétique
du pays sa dynamique économique et
l'approvisionnement des foyers français
d'autres facteurs dans votre prise en
compte comme par exemple l'interaction
entre les métiers de la filière qui doit
être garantie par la puissance publique
la coordination entre la gestion des
barrages hydroélectriques et le
refroidissement décentrales nucléaires
doit être assuré comment faire en cas de
privation par branche il en va de notre
sécurité nationale avant de conclure
j'évoquerai le texte transmis au Sénat
il comportait 6 articles et d'un compte
plus que trois
la majorité chez notoriale la vidéo de
sa substance car il télescoperait leur
achat par l'état des parts des petits
actionnaires minoritaires toujours en
cours
avec l'action de l'amendement auquel je
suis favorable tous mes collègues du
groupe RDSE élargissant à l'article 3
bises réglementaire pour les TPE
commerce de proximité rien ne justifie
la suppression de l'article premier
visant à renacher les élèves pour
garantir la propriété publique et
l'unité du service public de l'énergie
quant à l'article 2 modifiant le code de
l'énergie là aussi vider de sa substance
il oblige à passer par la loi en cas de
tentative de privatisation des activités
d'EDF
depuis la production le transport
lècheportation jusqu'au prestations de
maintenance et de sécurité
à titre personnel
sans rétablissement de l'article premier
à l'issue de nos débats je ne voterai
pas ce texte car je n'oublie pas
l'inquiétude des Français et du
gouvernement face au spectre des
coupures d'électricité durant l'hiver
qui viennent de s'achever je vous
remercie
vous êtes parfait
la parole est maintenant Madame
Christine Navarre pour le groupe les
républicains
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur alors la
PPL dont nous allons discuter de cet
après-midi traite de trois sujets le
dernier sans lien direct avec les deux
premiers que j'aborderai successivement
à savoir la nationalisation de DS sont
possibles des membrement et enfin
l'extension des tarifs réglementés de
vente de l'électricité alors sur la
nationalisation sans grande surprise le
groupe les républicains soutient le
travail du rapporteur et dont je
remercie ici et celle déjà été fait la
qualité qui a supprimé l'article premier
qui prévoyait la nationalisation alors
nous ne disons pas pour autant que la
garantie du non privatisation d'une
activité hautement stratégique au même
titre d'épée ne se pose pas et je vous
renvoie tous ici à ceux qui ont
participé au débat de la loi pacte en
effet la souveraineté énergétique de la
France repose sur EDF dont l'état
possédait déjà 84% des parts du capital
toutefois une montée au capital pour
passer à 100% et actuellement prévu 9
milliards 7 ont d'ailleurs été votés
dans le cadre du projet de loi de
rectificatif au mois de juillet dernier
dans le cadre d'une offre publique
d'achat simplifié à un prix de 12 euros
par action qui a été validé par le
conseil d'administration d'EDF alors
cette opération elle présente un
inconvénient à savoir que la procédure
échappe presque totalement au contrôle
du Parlement et c'est d'ailleurs une des
critiques qu'on exprimée les députés les
républicains tout en reconnaissant que
la nationalisation n'était certainement
pas la meilleure réponse à apporter et
donc nous partageons également cette
position l'eau passe étant en cours la
nationalisation n'a pas de justification
alors par cette offre publique d'achat
en fait l'État cherche à se donner les
moyens de mettre en oeuvre une politique
de relance du nucléaire nous avons envie
de vous croire même si c'est quand même
votre majorité je suis obligée de le
rappeler qui a mis fin au programme
Astrid en 2019 et je parle là sous le
contrôle du vice-président de l'OPEX
dont notre collègue Stéphane pianoard a
commis un rapport publié en juin en
juillet 2021 qui justement met en avant
toutes les les méfaits de cet abandon
pour la stratégie énergétique française
alors Monsieur le Ministre effectivement
relancer le nucléaire est un défi
technique quel type de réacteur
allons-nous construire mais c'est aussi
et surtout un défi financier aujourd'hui
le groupe EDF est très endetté c'est
regarder 64,5 milliards de dettes afin
2022 les investissements pour le
nucléaire sont considérables alors qu'il
pour le nouveau nucléaire alors qu'il
faut en même temps financer le programme
de grand carénage près de 60 milliards
d'euros en compte des impératifs
d'adaptation au changement climatiques
la commission des finances a travaillé
très récemment sur le sujet alors en
mars 2021 Bercy estimée que le programme
de 6 EPR 2 hors frais financier pour
écouter entre 52 et 57 milliards d'euros
je cite dans un scénario de bonne
maîtrise industrielle mais pour aller
jusqu'à 64 milliards d'euros dans un
scénario plus dégradé alors Monsieur le
Ministre pouvez-vous nous en dire plus
sur votre stratégie de financement j'ai
cru le lire ou comprendre qu'un appel
aux investisseurs étrangers pourraient
être envisagés cela ressort d'une visio
qui a eu en janvier 2021 l'ancien patron
d'EDF à savoir Jean-Bernard Lévy ou
encore qu'il pourrait être fait appel au
front du livret A qui jusqu'à présent me
semble être contre consacré au
financement du logement social donc vous
l'avez bien compris monsieur le ministre
si nous n'avons pas d'opposition à cette
offre publique d'achat nous avons de
véritables interrogations sur le
financement de la stratégie qui est pour
et à court terme cette OPA celle pose
une seule question qui est celle du
devenir des actionnaires salariés alors
depuis le 8 février 2023 date de clôture
provisoire de l'offre les tiens des tas
l'état des tiens près de 80 16% du
capital
1,17% restent encore détenu par les
salariés donc aujourd'hui rien n'oppose
n'empêche l'État en fait de se retirer
de la côte ça c'est techniquement
possible avec plus de 90% du capital
mais on remarque quand même que la
clôture définitive de l'opération a été
retardée notamment aujourd'hui parce que
l'État fait face à un procès de petits
actionnaires qui portent notamment sur
le prix de rachat des actions qui est
jugé trop faible alors dans les faits le
prix de rachat fixé à 12 euros constitue
en fait une prime par rapport à la
valorisation du marché de court terme de
l'entreprise je vous rappelle qu'au mois
de juillet l'action est descendue après
de 7 euros mais pour les salariés qui
regardent en fait le prix auquel ils ont
acheté à savoir
20 32 euros pour les non salariés et
25,6 euros en 2005 pour les salariés
c'est une véritable perte puisqu'il y a
une division par plus de deux du cours
si on ajoute à ça l'inflation autant
vous dire que la perte est encore
beaucoup plus importante
alors ces petits actionnaires au nombre
de 82000 salariés ou ancien salarié il
souhaite être maintenu au capital et la
justice se penchera enfin rendra sa
décision dans le procès en cours le 2
mai prochain alors pour cranter dans la
loi le passage d'EDF à 100% dans le
Gironde l'état la commission des
finances à l'initiative de Gérard
Longuet a inscrit dans la PPL l'objectif
d'une détention du capital à hauteur de
100% au plus tard le 1er jumelier 2024
et donc taxe initiale de la commune dans
le texte de la commission celui dont
nous discutons 2% de ce capital pouvait
toutefois être accordée aux salariés ou
aux anciens salariés d'EDF alors je vous
avoue et nous en avons eu des
discussions en commission des finances
que je m'interroge en fait sur la mise
contre la mise en oeuvre concrète de
cette disposition notamment puisque dans
la mesure où l'offre publique d'achat
prévoit une montée à 100% du capital par
l'État on se demande ensuite comment il
serait possible dans rétrocéder 2% au
salarié je m'interroge aussi sur
l'intérêt en fait pour des petits
actionnaires parce qu'ils vont se
trouver avec une action qui n'est pas
liquide à partir du moment où
l'entreprise n'est plus cotée par
ailleurs en fait aujourd'hui il faut
quand même se le dire je vous ai parlé
de la date mais l'entreprise n'est pas
du tout profitable en 2022 elle a fait
près de 18 milliards d'euros de pertes
alors pour différentes raisons
l'existence du mécanisme d'arène ce
mécanisme doit disparaître en janvier
enfin en 2025 on ne connaît pas des
suites qui seront donnés mais ces suites
ont des conséquences très fortes sur la
rentabilité du groupe
voilà ça c'est des vrais sujets sur
lequel il va falloir avoir des
explications et donc aujourd'hui je me
demande si en fait un versement de
dividendes sera possible pour ses
salariés pour ces actionnaires tant les
besoins d'investissement sont très
importants aujourd'hui déjà en fait en
termes de trésorerie EDF empreinte entre
1,5 et 3 milliards d'euros par an pour
venir verser des dividendes et c'est
d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle
depuis 2016 en fait l'état ne demande
plus de versement de dividendes en cash
mais récupère en fait avec des
des actions ils montaient de capital
pour justement soulager la trésorerie de
l'entreprise alors j'ai bien vu que le
gouvernement a déposé un amendement à la
proposition de la commission dont
j'avoue ne pas avoir beaucoup mieux
compris en quoi il serait il répondrait
mieux entre guillemets à ses
interrogations donc nous aurons je pense
très certainement l'occasion dans des
battre tout à l'heure sur le
démondrement je vais pas rappeler ici le
projet Hercule qui avait été envisagé en
2019 qui a été abandonné depuis juste
pour vous dire que le groupe LR du Sénat
lui n'a pas d'opposition de principe à
ce qui a pu être écrit dans une note
adressée à l'autorité des marchés
financiers à savoir poursuivre le plan
de section d'actifs à hauteur d'environ
3 milliards d'euros entre 2022 et 2024
nous n'avons pas d'opposition dès lors
bien sûr que ces décisions participeront
d'une stratégie d'indépendance
énergétique et de décarbonation donc
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
soutenons pleinement la réécriture de
l'article 2 l'état possèdera désormais
une entreprise qui agit le cadre fixé
par le code de l'énergie et cette
nouvelle rédaction elle permet notamment
de lever un certain nombre de risques
qui pesaient sur les filiales de DF et
notamment RTE enfin et pour finir sur
les extensions des tarifs réglementés de
vente alors les députés socialistes eux
ont prévu une mesure qui est d'une part
d'un coup financier très important alors
le gouvernement nous annonce 18
milliards pour tous ceux qui étaient
dans cette miss cycle au mois de
décembre j'avoue que nous avons toujours
maintenant de une suspicion en fait
quand le gouvernement nous annonce des
chiffrages en matière de dispositif
d'énergie nous souvenons d'un sous
amendement assimilial enfin comme nous
attendons toujours les chiffres à
l'appui des assertions qui ont été
faites au mois de décembre nous vous
accorderons un crédit limité sur le coût
de la mesure mais j'entends que ça doit
quand même être très onéreux puisque
l'application de l'article 13 du
règlement européen d'octobre 2022
prévoit que l'État dans un déniiser les
fournisseurs dès lors qu'ils vendent à
perte enfin cette extension aux
entreprises de taille intermédiaires les
GTI lui et contraire au droit européen
puisque les a d’état sont temporaires
sont possibles uniquement pour les TPME
donc par contre nous vous rejoignons sur
l'objectif de la mesure qui était en
fait d'apporter une réponse au petites
entreprises que les boulangers
particulièrement mais aussi au
collectivités dont certaines en fait se
trouvent exclus des tarifs réglementés
alors même qu'elle remplissent les
critères de chiffre d'affaires ou de
budget et de nombre de salariés mais
elles ont un besoin de souscrire une
puissance installée forte parce que par
exemple pour une collectivité c'est une
grosse pompe à chaleur pour les
boulangers c'est un four et donc cette
solution de supprimer la mention de 36
qui avait elle est très pertinente je
veux juste vous faire remarquer ici
qu'en fait dès le début on aurait pu le
faire parce qu'il me semble que ça
relève du pouvoir réglementaire et qu'il
aurait été beaucoup plus facile de
corriger une erreur dans domaine du
règlement que de devoir corriger une
erreur dans la loi et enfin pour finir
juste pour vous dire qu'à l'instar de ce
que mon collègue Daniel grimillier avait
pu dire au moment de l'ouverture du
texte sur le nucléaire aujourd'hui j'ai
quand même l'impression qu'il nous
manque une vision c'est à dire que
depuis plusieurs mois on pas mal de
briques briques sur le nucléaire brique
sur les énergies renouvelables
aujourd'hui brique sur EDF mais on a pas
vraiment le plan du mur qu'on est en
train de construire alors vous allez me
dire que tout ça va arriver bientôt
puisque
c'est terminé
la parole est à Monsieur Emmanuel Capu
pour 4 minutes pour le groupe Les
Indépendants
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre
mes chers collègues monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur le Président mes
chers collègues le problème d'une
entreprise nationale c'est que sa
stratégie dépend du calendrier électoral
c'est une évidence qu'il me semble utile
de rappeler en préambule alors que des
éloges de l'État actionnaire vont fuser
à gauche comme à droite
or les cycles d'investissement
industriels s'inscrivent dans le temps
long il s'accorde mal avec le calendrier
électoral
aujourd'hui un consensus politique c'est
pourtant formé autour de la
nationalisation d'EDF ce point d’accord
est un fait rare car en matière de
politique énergétique l'accord et
l'exception et le désaccord la règle
depuis la Seconde Guerre mondiale il n'y
a eu que deux grands accords historiques
le premier c'est le Conseil National de
la Résistance
les auteurs de la proposition de loi s'y
réfèrent d'ailleurs abondamment et nos
collègues socialistes salut l’œuvre du
général de Gaulle avec une ferveur qui
je l'avoue ne laisse pas insensible
le second accord historique c'est le
virage du tout nucléaire avec le plan
Messmer de 1974 grande année la France
s'est alors engagée dans la construction
du plus grand parc nucléaire au monde je
pensais pas à ça
se développements industriel n'a pas été
remise en cause par les gouvernements
suivants cette remarquable constance a
permis à EDF de bâtir un actif
stratégique hors du commun qui a très
largement contribué à la prospérité de
la France grâce à une électricité
abondante et peu cher
pour justifier la nationalisation d'ef
les auteurs du texte dressent le
parallèle entre la France de 2023 et
celle de 1946 mais à vrai dire mes chers
collègues la situation actuelle
ressemble bien plus au premier choc
pétrolier qu'à la Seconde Guerre
mondiale la crise énergétique découle
d'une guerre qui ne se lui produit pas
sur notre sol mais nous dont nous
suitons indirectement les conséquences
et qui nous obligent à agir
et d'ailleurs comme il y a 50 ans la
nation se rassemble aujourd'hui autour
d'un objectif garantir la souveraineté
énergétique en construisant de nouveaux
réacteurs c'est tout le projet me
semble-t-il du gouvernement qui a
annoncé reprendre la possession de EDF
afin de garder la maîtrise du parc
nucléaire
nos collègues socialistes reprochent
encore au gouvernement de nationaliser
EDF pour mieux la saucissonner c'est
assez fort de café alors que c'est la
gauche qui a orchestré la mise à mal de
la filière nucléaire française sous
François Hollande
puisqu'on sait depuis 2015 qu'il suffit
d'une loi pour fragiliser l'avenir de
notre industrie nucléaire je ne suis pas
certain qu'une proposition de loi
pourrait garantir quoi que ce soit
pour moi les choses sont assez claires
le gouvernement veut nationaliser UDF
elle Parlement soutien cette initiative
le reste n'est que spéculation sur
l'avenir
à l'initiative de notre collègue Gérard
Longuet rapporteur la commission des
finances a largement réécrit le texte je
salue ses travaux notre groupe préfère
très nettement cette nouvelle mosure et
qui a le mérite de limiter la portée
législative du texte cette version a
également le mérite de mettre en
conformité ce texte avec le droit
européen alors que l'Europe à plus que
jamais besoin d'union face à la Russie
face à la Chine fasse même parfois à nos
alliés américains il ne s'agit pas là
d'un détail c'est la raison pour
laquelle le groupe se partagera entre un
vote positif et une abstention je vous
remercie
merci ma parole est maintenant Monsieur
Daniel Brouillet pour le groupe écologie
solidarité territoire
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur monsieur
le Président de la Commission chers
collègues je salue la proposition de loi
présentée et portée par Philippe Brun à
l'Assemblée nationale qui s'inscrit
pleinement dans la dynamique du projet
des écologistes pour une république
écologique dans le cadre des
présidentielles 2022
renationaliser Électricité de France et
en faire un outil stratégique puissant
cohérent au service de la transition
énergétique alors bien sûr la commission
des finances a supprimé le premier
article de cette proposition de loi qui
formalisait un acte de nationalisation
préférant une étatisation à supprimer
l'énumération des filiales constitutives
du groupe public unifié visant à
s'opposer au démantèlement du groupe
bref la commission des finances a
décousu cette PPL bien que le projet
Hercule je vous entends monsieur le
ministre s'il n'existe plus puissent
cacher un Hercule bis les choix
énergétiques pour notre pays peuvent
diverger les nôtres sont ici largement
minoritaires et vous les connaissez mais
lorsque l'on défend le choix du
nucléaire on doit aussi défendre un
outil 100% public chaque décision de
l'État bouclier tarifaire relèvement des
volumes de la reine grand carénage
construction de 6 EPR pèsent sur les
comptes d'EDF dont la situation est déjà
particulièrement dégradée à cela
s'ajoute l'incompréhension totale des
Françaises et des Français sur le coup
de l'énergie l'énergie l'accès à
l'énergie joue aussi un rôle social des
sociétales c'est un bien de première
nécessité qui comme l'eau doit être
traité en ce sens un bien commun
essentiel les 15% de restent à charge du
bouclier tarifaire non pas le même
impact selon qu'on habite une passoire
thermique qu'on est en situation de
précarité ce sont les revenus modestes
qui sont malheureusement toujours les
premières victimes de ces hausses du
coût de la vie les bailleurs sociaux
craignent une hausse des impayés les
syndicats de copropriétaires font face
également à des difficultés nouvelles
comme les 10 ans commerçants TPE et je
souligne sur ce point notre accord avec
l'amendement du rapporteur pour
supprimer le plafond des 36
kwa seul un tiers des entreprises
concernées par le bouclier tarifaire on
concrétisé une demande d'aide les
collectivités quant à elles ne savent
toujours pas dans quelle mesure elle
bénéficieront ou non des aides de l'État
la PPA d'initiale propose un accès pour
tous au tarif réglementés on pourrait
attendre de la chambre des territoires
un plein soutien à cette revendication
de bon sens pour nos collègues maires la
situation est grave les écologistes a
l'air depuis de nombreuses années sur
l'urgence à s'engager fortement dans les
énergies décarbonées sur la fin de
l'abondance la mise hors marchés et or
surconsommation de l'énergie si l'État
ne peut pas tout prévoir il a une
obligation de préparer l'avenir la
concurrence ouverte la politique du prix
bas les stratégies tout nucléaires
encore aujourd'hui ne favorise pas selon
nous une réorientation des politiques
énergétique en cohérence avec le rapport
du GIEC et les dérèglements climatiques
et encore moins une maîtrise des coûts
qui est pourtant espérée souvent
proclamé sur ses bancs EDF pourrait
redevenir le bras armé de notre pays
pour une nouvelle politique énergétique
la proposition de loi de Philippe Brun
répond à cet axe majeur et stratégique
du retour de DF sous le contrôle de
l'État il serait inadmissible de voir
les aspects rentables du groupe comme le
développement des énergies renouvelables
être privatisées selon la bonne vieille
méthode libérale privatise privatisée
les bénéfices et nationalisés les pertes
et les déficits j'asservrai j'achèverai
ce propos en évoquant la place des
citoyens et des salariés dans ce débat à
quel moment les Françaises et les
Français ont-ils été associés à ces
décisions et aux orientations prises par
le gouvernement serait-il d'accord pour
financer des réacteurs dont le modèle je
voudrais le rappeler on l'oublie souvent
flamant ville 1 19,1 milliard d'après la
Cour des comptes quand il devait en
coûter 3,3 un débat national sur les
choix énergétiques de la France est
indispensable il est même essentiel ces
choix ne peuvent se faire sans une
nation éclairée aux enjeux climatiques à
leurs conséquences pour l'avenir
monsieur Julien margeton vous avez la
parole pour le groupe de Rassemblement
démocratique progressiste et indépendant
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur monsieur
le Président de la Commission
donc ce texte notre groupe je le dis
tout de suite votre acompte pourquoi le
travail du rapporteur est impressionnant
je le remercie d'ailleurs ça
démonstration était brillante pour
autant la question que nous posons c'est
pourquoi voter ce texte
qui ne propose plus grand chose le texte
avait été créé pour
nationaliser
EDF finalement évidemment le
gouvernement a répondu ça a été dit il y
a une opas en cours et donc ça ne se
justifie plus le rapporteur lui-même dès
l'Assemblée nationale a d'ailleurs
changé le titre de sa loi en commission
et puis il avait proposé un rachat à 14
euros qui finalement est plus cher que
celui proposé ça coûtait un milliard et
demi de plus pour les finances publiques
c'était dommage donc ce point là est
abandonné et dans sa sagesse le Sénat a
supprimé l'article premier c'est plus
pas la peine dit revenu alors il reste
un deuxième point qui est le point
évidemment sur le groupe unifié et là
aussi finalement on fait un procès
d'intention gouvernement procéder
d'attention on a beau le répéter projet
Hercule est abandonné mais on répète que
il faut quand même protéger etc alors là
il y a évidemment l'abandon également de
la formule qui avait été proposée alors
l'article 2 certes lui n'est pas
entièrement supprimé mais enfin il est
largement amodié et son contenu et
finalement réduit à sa plus simple
expression et il n'apporte rien par
rapport à la situation existante
troisième point ça a été souligné par
tous les orateurs le tarif tarif
réglementé de vente là aussi nous avons
eu les explications du rapporteur et
donc sur le tarif fragmenté de vente la
première rédaction était une rédaction
qui était contraire au droit européen
heureusement notre rapporteur le Sénat a
proposé finalement un dispositif
extrêmement réduit extrêmement restreint
qui évite les difficultés auxquelles se
heurtaient et quand on regarde ça
finalement nous avons un texte assez
squelettiques tel qu'il reste et encore
c'est quand les archéologues trouvent
des squelettes incomplets c'est à dire
bon trouver un bout mais on trouve pas
l'ensemble
il n'y a plus de nationalisation il n'y
a plus de statut spécifique il n'y a
plus finalement aucune des réponses à ce
qui correspond à l'objet et au titre de
la loi initiale donc dans ce cadre là
avec un texte aussi privé de sa
substance vous comprendrez que le groupe
de la majorité s'y opposera merci
beaucoup
je vous remercie la parole est
maintenant à Victor Hurel pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicain
[Musique]
on l'a vu en 74 le plan Messmer mettre
en place
56 réacteurs engagés pendant une
vingtaine d'années des baisses de prix
et faire
un prix moyen
28% inférieur au prix moyen européen 17
cm à peu près du kilowatt-heure 28
centimes du kilowatt-heure pour
l'Allemagne ce qui donnait un avantage
compétitif considérable à la France ce
qui est plus tout à fait le cas
aujourd'hui et bien hélas mon rêve est
en train de sombrer dans les marécages
de l'idéologie
ce rêve de consensus transpartisan que
nous souhaiterions et que nous appelions
de nos vœux
nous dit que ce qui s'est fait la barre
on peut leur répéter ici en préservant
l'essentiel
et là ce on voit à la faveur de ce texte
affronté de vision de vision
diamétralement opposée un peu
orthogonal de dire que
l'étatisation n'est pas une
nationalisation et que le texte proposé
par félibon et par le groupe socialiste
mais par toute la gauche en général et
un taxi a du souffle et qui porte si
j'ose dire une âme
nationaliser c'est rendre à la nation et
ça implique au moins deux choses c'est
le transfert des moyens de production
mais c'est aussi l'utilisation de ces
moyens de production en faveur des
usagers en faveur des citoyens et en
faveur de la nation
or ce qui s'est fait depuis
2000 et à la faveur de toutes les
directives qui ont été prises depuis 96
ensuite en 2003 en 2009 en 2010 en 2019
bien ça a été
une ouverture des fenêtres ça a commencé
c'est vrai par les salariés depuis 73
une fenêtre ouverte pour des
filialisations pour des hybridations
pour des croisements de de capital
parfois donc des privatisations
rampantes
ce que propose le groupe socialiste sera
proposé notre collègue député c'est de
dire retrouvons et insufflons une âme
nouvelle et ne confions pas simplement
EDF qui est le moteur de la Sauveur
intelle énergétique du pays nous le
confions pas à une élite quel que soit
sa qualité quel que soit les grands
comités
et la souveraineté énergétique du pays a
une élite à une techno structure qui ne
fait qu'une seule chose c'est de dire je
me soumets
le terme est fort
je veux pas reprendre ce qui est pu être
écrit de manière affreuse en littérature
on se soumet et j'avoue et je m'adresse
à Gérard Longuet notre excellent
[Musique]
verticalement intégré d'intérêt général
et d'intérêt national ça équivaut un
ministère de la défense c'est la défense
de la France ce que on n'a pas su faire
on passe à côté au motif vidéo logique
il faut faire la tarification au coût
marginal qu'il faut corréler le prix de
l'électricité à la dernière unité mise
en œuvre à savoir du lignée tout peut
être du charbon allemand mais c'est ça
malheureusement le problème et quand on
veut descendre pour l'usage des Français
pour le plus grand bien des Français de
dire il faut interve qui soit à la
disposition de tous non on change le
mode de calcul et c'est le coût
d'approvisionnement du fournisseur
alternatif qui n'a de fournisseurs que
le nom c'est ça aujourd'hui le modèle
qui est soumis et auquel nous nous
soumettons tous je le regrette vraiment
il nous faut un champion national il
faut donc la nationalisation d'EDF avec
défense des intérêts de la France il
faut
délimiter le périmètre pour éviter les
sessions il faut un tr- revue et corrigé
et voilà ce que nous remettons pas
amendement dans le texte qui vous est
soumis nous réservons le vote en
attendant en étant timistes que vous
ferez un sort je l'espère favorable
un parole est à Fabien gay pour le
groupe républicain communiste
commissaire c'est
ça arrive comme une républicain comme
une républicain citoyen et écologiste
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues la crise
énergétique n'est pas seulement le
résultat de la guerre en Ukraine comme
vous essayez de le faire croire il ne
suffira pas non plus de délier les prix
du gaz l'électricité ou d'ajuster le
marché européen comme vous venez
d'ailleurs de le faire au profit de la
compétitivité allemande parce que le
résultat c'est d'abord celui de l'Europe
libérale de la fracturation de notre
entreprise intégrée historique EDF en
plusieurs entités et de traders qui
spéculent et touche des dividendes
records que dira encore de la reine ce
raquette organisée sur le dos d'EDF et
des usagers qui affaiblissent la
capacité d'investissement qui enrichit
les acteurs alternatifs et qui cassent
progressivement les tarifs réglementés
de vente de l'électricité ce bilan c'est
le vôtre et celui de l'alliance de tous
les libéraux pour faire de l'énergie une
marchandise comme une autre alors que
c'est un monopole de fait et qu'elle
doit donc être sortie du marché et
considéré comme un bien commun alors la
droite sonatoriale est à l'offensive au
moins dans les mots indépendance
énergétique souveraineté réforme du
marché européen protection nos
collectivités mais quand il faut passer
aux actes il n'y a plus personne nous
vous avons proposé en décembre le retour
au tarif réglementé pour toutes les
collectivités vous l'avez refusé sortir
du marché européen en janvier et faire
valoir notre exception d'une production
nucléaire à bas coût vous l'avez refusé
et aujourd'hui une loi sur la
nationalisation d'EDF refusée ou tout du
moins bien amputé de l'ambition initiale
du texte de nos collègues socialistes je
veux d'ailleurs saluer leur proposition
de loi qui voulait un groupe unifier
avec des actions nonessibles pour éviter
la vente d'actifs comme dalker ou enedis
et qui vous empêcherait de réactiver
votre projet Hercule que la majorité des
salariés des IOG ont rejeté aujourd'hui
tout le monde l'aura compris la
situation ne viendra pas de vous et de
vos mesurettes pour corriger un système
qui est voué à s'effondrer 70 ans après
l'oeuvre du père d'EDF et
[Musique]
des instrument fondamental de la vie du
pays vous qui avez tout détruit et qui
voulait continuer vous nous trouverez
sur votre route avec ses petits-enfants
et arrière petits-enfants prêts à tout
reconstruire je vous remercie
merci
en fin d'année
pour le groupe Union centriste
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre le groupe de l'Union centriste
voudrait tout d'abord remercier
sincèrement le rapporteur du texte
Gérard Longuet pour la pertinence de ces
analyses et la manière dont il a exposé
la situation car finalement on est sur
un texte qui par notre fête aborde tout
simplement la politique énergétique de
notre pays puisque c'est cela qu'il
s'agit on a eu d'autres textes qui l'ont
évoqué je pense au texte sur le
nucléaire ou l'accélération du nucléaire
ou le texte sur l'accélération des
énergies renouvelables mais je crois que
le débat n'a pas été clos et il mérite
d'être largement poursuivi et c'est
l'occasion
de ce texte de le faire monsieur le
ministre alors le groupe de l'Union
centriste disons-le clairement est
attaché à ce qui est un mix énergétique
qui permet d'assurer véritablement la
souveraineté de notre pays en la matière
le énergétique d'ailleurs ne doit pas
s'arrêter à l'électricité je crois qu'il
faut aussi que l'on soit attentif à
l'énergie d'origine du gaz par exemple
du gaz bien sûr renouvelable mais aussi
d'autres formes de production
énergétique qui sont importantes pour
pouvoir permettre demain à notre pays
d'être particulièrement souverain
autonome en matière d'énergie et chacun
sait est particulièrement le ministre de
l'Industrie que vous êtes combien
l'énergie est un élément indispensable
pour la compétitivité de nos entreprises
alors sur cette nationalisation bien sûr
je ne partage pas du tout les propos qui
viennent d'être tenus par notre collègue
Fabien gay non d'avoir
un système monolithique ne permettrait
pas de répondre au défi que auquel nous
sommes affrontés dans cette perspective
énergétique tout simplement parce qu'il
faut qu'on trouve une multitude de
solutions et cette multitude de
solutions
cherchera bien sûr la panache d'un grand
nombre d'opérateurs et si ces opérateurs
peuvent effectivement dans le cadre
légal que nous assituons pouvoir
s'exprimer et bien nous pourrons
apporter des réponses aux besoins de nos
concitoyens en la matière alors
disons-le assez clairement aussi
peut-être qu'il faut s'interroger sur la
perspective de nationalisation de d'EDF
parce que finalement ça coûte beaucoup
d'argent plus de 8 milliards d'euros
était une nécessaire de procéder à cette
nationalisation ne valait-elle pas mieux
consacrée cet argent important à
moderniser notre parc de production
c'est franchement une question dont il
faut se poser mais ceci étant la
décision a été prise donc il faut qu'on
en prenne acte et nous le faisons au
niveau du groupe de l'Union centriste
alors ce texte bien sûr aborde de
différentes choses sur cette
sur cette acquisition d'action
nous dirions que dans l'esprit de ce que
fut la loi pacte
voté il y a cinq ans nous pensons que il
faut quand même favoriser l'actionnariat
populaire l'actionnariat salarié en
particulier la question du partage de la
valeur et pour nous membres du groupe de
l'Union centriste quelque chose
d'important et nous nous interrogeons
c'est vrai sur l'amendement que le
gouvernement a déposé limitant les
choses et nous préférions que nous en
tenir à la rédaction du rapporteur car
il nous semblait qu'il avait trouvé le
juste compromis en la matière donc nous
pensons que il faut quand même tenir
compte de l'importance de la motivation
de l'ensemble des salariés d'EDF et puis
le rapporteur a également évoqué bien
sûr une des principales dispositions du
texte qui concerne l'extension du tarif
réglementé
[Musique]
pourquoi la proposition du rapporteur de
l'assemblée est particulièrement
pertinente à cet égard voilà donc
quelques éléments que nous souhaitions
pouvoir
évoquer aujourd'hui et puis nous allons
pouvoir nous exprimer également dans le
débat qui s'ouvre à l'instant merci de
votre attention
merci
la discussion générale est close nous
passons donc maintenant à l'addition à
la discussion du texte de la Commission
à l'article premier d'abord Monsieur
Franck Montauger
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre cher collègue
les expressions en discussion générale
que nous venons d'entendre l'ont montré
il y a en réalité dans cette émission
deux approches très différentes
celles libérale très libérale de la
commission des finances et de son
rapporteur Gérard Longuet qui laisse
ouverte toutes les options de cession
ultérieure de filiales
et celles la nôtre
centrée sur le confortement de notre
souveraineté industrielle en matière
d'énergie décarbonée
nous voulons garder dans le giron
national EDF et toutes ces filiales cœur
de métiers la production dans toutes ses
formes énergies renouvelables
hydraulique nucléaire thermique le
transport et la distribution RTE et
enedis sans rien toucher au prérogatives
et au statut particulier eu égard au
droit européen qui sont les leurs
ainsi que les services services
énergétiques que rend le groupe
aujourd'hui comme les imports et les
exports d'électricité monsieur le
ministre vous avez laissé entendre que
c'était le marché européen qui avait
institué de l'exportation et de
l'importation
l'exportation et l'importation
existaient bien avant la mise en place
du marché européen je tiens à le
rappeler ici
comme je tiens à dire que porter la part
du capital de dfsa à 100%
pour l'État n'empêchera pas des sessions
de capital ou de filiales
ultérieurement et je regrette la porte
reste ouverte pour des opérations de
restructuration comme Hercule
voilà
l'objet de ce texte était de garantie
d'apporter des garanties par rapport à
ça ça ne sera pas le cas donc ce que
nous voulons je le répète c'est une
société EDF nationalisée dans le cadre
d'un groupement public unifié et ça sera
le sens des amendements que nous allons
défendre
la parole est maintenant monsieur
Victoria Murel
[Musique]
j'appartiens
à la nationalisation à une loi de
nationalisation de l'entreprise
EDF
EDF n'est pas une simple entreprise
c'est une arme
c'est un bouclier
et penser un seul instant que une
opération
[Musique]
simplifiée une offre publique d'achat
donc une étatisation donc une montée en
capital suffit pour garantir l'unité la
cohérence l'intégration et éviter les
dérives que l'on a pu constater pendant
une vingtaine d'années dans la gestion
et le management de cette entreprise est
une illusion c'est la question pour
laquelle nous tenons au principe de la
nationalisation inscrite dans le
préambule de la constitution de 46 est
repris dans le bloc de constituation
qui est le nôtre à savoir ça doit
devenir bien commun bien de la nation
qui doit être transférer ses moyens de
production transférées mais surtout
utilisez au bénéfice des nationaux voilà
ce que l'on dit pour autant on ne dit
pas de s'enfermer et de ne pas faire
dans l'International on ne dit pas ne
pas faire dans la rotation d'actifs on
veut préserver le cœur de métier de EDF
c'est la raison de notre amendement
savoir une entreprise nationaliser
est-ce que c'est vous qui présentez
l'amendement numéro 2
c'est fait mais je le répète ça me donne
juste un temps pour dire on veut
consolider et unifier EDF et tenir à ce
que Philippe Brun appelait un groupe
public unifié on le fait pour la SNCF
j'ai entendu moi des arguments assez
spéciaux pour dire oh c'est une simple
occurrence et qu'on ne pourrait pas le
répéter non on le répète et on a vu nos
collègues communistes Fabien gay déposer
un amendement sur le CNR pour dire mais
ça s'appelle bien une société anonyme
intégrer
intégré on l'a proposé en commission ça
a été refusé le mot national a été
retenu mais on tient donc à cette entité
et à au concept national et de
nationalisation
merci alors avant de donner la parole à
Fabien gay pour présenter l'amendement
numéro 8 qui est identique j'informe le
Sénat et que je suis saisie d'un
chapelet de demande de scrutin public
sur ces articles et ce qui vous
permettra de vous préparer allez-y
quand il peut appeler ça un chapelet
merci madame la Présidente
nous nous tenons comme nos collègues
socialistes au retour de l'article 1er
et au terme nationalisation parce que ce
n'est pas exactement sur le ministre ce
que vous êtes en train de faire en
rachetant les actions des actionnaires
minoritaires qui étaient institutionnels
ou actionnariat salariés ce que vous
faites en ce moment c'est une
étatisation et vous sortez EDF de la
Bourse c'est à dire que EDF ne sera plus
côté en bourse ça sera donc une
entreprise
qui aura un capital 100% public mais
dans lequel et vous le savez très bien
puisque ça sera toujours sa structure
une sa société anonyme vous créerez une
holding comme vous avez fait la SNCF et
d'autres entreprises publiques ce qui ne
vous empêche pas deux choses d'abord un
de filialiser la deuxième chose de CD
des actifs dont Dalkia enedis et il va
falloir que votre gouvernement réponde
est-ce que oui ou non vous voulez céder
Dalkia enedis et la troisième chose
c'est que la holding de tête sera 100%
national mais ça vous empêche pas en
réalité de céder aussi et d'ouvrir à des
filiales à des capitaux privés et donc
ce n'est pas exactement la même chose
que vous êtes en train de faire et le
projet que nous voulons la
nationalisation et je me permettrai mais
dans un débat à gauche tranquillement je
pense que nous devrions ajouter à
nationalisation la transformation de la
société et elle sort en épique et
tamisement public que nous connaissons
extrêmement bien donc ce ne sont pas des
fonctionnaires ce sont des assimilés et
le statut des IOG va avec mais la
transformation en épique elle nous
garantit d'autres choses donc je vous le
dis monsieur le ministre il nous tenons
à ce que l'article premier soit rétabli
comme l'avait adopté l'Assemblée
nationale merci
y a-t-il d'autres
pardon il a vu de la Commission sur ces
deux âmes
identiques monsieur le ministre
pour une explication de vote
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre cher collègue
je redis ici la nécessité de
nationaliser le groupe EDF
pour éviter tout démantèlement ou des
membrement et d'ores et déjà ce stade du
débat je voudrais attirer votre
attention et ça permettra peut-être au
ministre de nous répondre dans quelques
instants sur la la problématique parce
que ça n'est une des 2% de capital
propriétés des salariés
cette disposition va fragiliser
l'hydraulique la production hydraulique
et probablement réouvrir le débat
relatif à la mise en concurrence des
concessions hydrauliques
donc ça serait ça serait une première
étape de démantèlement de démembrement
de l'entreprise obligatoire
qu'évidemment on veut éviter et qu'on
pourrait éviter effectivement en votant
cet article premier appelant à la
nationalisation du groupe EDF
c'est pas une petite affaire
c'est avéré en termes de risque
juridique et je voudrais que le
gouvernement peut être le rapporteur
nous éclaire là dessus
parce que les conséquences pourrait être
considérable considérable je vous
remercie
merci je vais donc monsieur bruyez vous
à la parole
merci madame la Présidente je comprends
bien sûr le choix de l'étatisation fait
par le gouvernement et soutenu par le
rapporteur la situation actuelle d'EDF
le coût du grand carénage le coût très
optimiste des six premiers Européens
trois fois moins cher que flamand ville
tout ça suppose effectivement qu'il
puisse y avoir un acteur public
c'est-à-dire nous-mêmes les
contribuables pour venir
financer ses dépenses considérables
mais ce n'est rien à voir avec le projet
initial de nationalisation c'est un
autre choix qui a été proposé par nos
collègues et qui est défendu sur ces
bancs de la gauche le choix d'avoir
effectivement un outil des politiques
énergétiques donc évidemment je voterai
ces deux amendements identiques de mes
collègues l'URL et gay au nom de mon
groupe et je le redis il est temps
d'avoir un débat sur la politique
énergétique de notre pays et pas de
débattre par petites tranches tranches
de prière tranche d'accélération ou
débat de cet après-midi de ces sujets
bien s'il n'y a plus de demandes
d'explication de vote sur ces amandes
monsieur
qu'il faut avancer non mais je trouve
dommage quand même que en une minute le
ministre nous répond pas quand même on a
posé des questions sur la question la
différence entre rétatisation et
nationalisation et on vous pose une
question simple est-ce que vous vous
engagez ici devant le Parlement en CD
aucun actif enedis et dalkera par
exemple pourraient nous dire ce que vous
êtes très à propos pour dire il y aura
pas d'Hercule très bien on en doute mais
est-ce qu'il y aura oui ou non des
sessions d'actifs puisque il n'y a pas
de projet caché dites-le ici devant le
Parlement a engagez-vous au moins sur
cette question je vous remercie madame
la Présidente très bien je vais donc il
n'y a plus d'explication de vote je vais
donc mettre ouvrir le scrutin public
dont nous avons été saisis pour les
amendements 2 et 8 par le groupe les
républicains le scrutin est ouvert
ne demande à voter le scrutin est clos
votant 343 exprimé 338 pour 99 contre
239 le Sénat n'a pas adopté et l'article
ayant été supprimés nous passons aux
amendements à l'article 2 et nous
commençons par trois amendements
communes le numéro 3 monsieur duel c'est
vous qui présentez
cet article
cet amendement
l'amendement numéro 3
c'est bien ça
c'est pas inscrit c'est ça au tableau de
décalage entre mon tableau
nous tenons à voir
rétabli la version originelle et à
délimiter le périmètre des activités de
l'entreprise EDF SA
en production en transport et un
transport en Z et demi en distribution
commercialisation et en prestation de
service énergétique alors il y a une
nuance c'est vrai qu'on a corrigé la
chose sur le transport autant on veut
voir EDF rester si j'ose dire une
présence capitalistique au sein de RTE
et je dirais enedis autant nous
respectons l'indépendance opérationnelle
et stratégique de de RTE donc l'écriture
telle qu'elle est soumise et conforme
aux droits européen et conforme au code
de l'énergie
vous nous présenter l'amendement neuf
et le 10 en deux minutes
non non en 2 minutes je suis d'accord
avec le rapporteur tout à l'heure qui a
dit qu'on avait déjà un groupe des
intégré puisque c'est vrai qu'avant EDF
produisait transporté distribué
aujourd'hui ce n'est plus le cas pour
des questions de concurrence juste pour
donner
un peu qu'on fasse un peu le bilan de la
libéralisation donc aujourd'hui
enedis transporte mais dans le transport
vous savez de l'électricité comme vous
l'accompagnez d'un point à un point B
vous en perdez c'est comme ça vous
partez à 100 et vous arrivez à 95 donc
enedis doit racheter de l'électricité
mais peut pas le faire à EDF qu'il a
détient pourtant quasi à 100% et doit
donc la racheter au marché à des
concurrents directs et notamment la
reine et donc s'approvisionnement
marraine mais chez les concurrents
directs de DF pour lui-même réinjecter
dans le réseau pour servir ses
concurrent direct vous voyez lorsqu'on
sait tout ça évidemment c'est
extrêmement compliqué mais quand même
bravo vous avez réalisé un chef-d'oeuvre
d'une usine à gaz qui conduit quand même
à des aberrations totales et quand on
voit en 20 ans libéralisation du secteur
l'énergie qui est un monopole de fait et
qui donc doit être sorti du marché tout
ce que coûté à notre pays a EDF sur le
dos des usagers franchement on en est
plus là et donc je repose la question
comme ce ministre est-ce que on va
garder un groupe intégré et est-ce qu'il
y aura oui ou non des sessions d'actifs
avaient la réintissatisation que vous
voulez et notamment Dalkia et enedis et
voilà je vous rends même 15 secondes
madame la présidentielle merci quelle
est la ville de la Commission sur ces
trois amendements
la commission madame la Présidente est
défavorable à ces trois amendements je
reconnais la volonté de Victorin Lurel
et son groupe de s'efforcer de d'obtenir
une votre conforme à celui de
l'assemblée et de faire
des gestes d'ouverture sur les réalités
d'un marché qui est désormais chère
Fabien gay parfaitement concurrentiel et
personne ne songe à le remettre et quand
vous dites que oui je naturellement mais
vous êtes assez largement minoritaire en
France et en Europe ce qui pose un
problème pour l'autorité et
l'aboutissement de vos propres projets
il se trouve que l'électricité est
désormais produite de façon très
différente nous avons en effet le
système nucléaire qui est un système
unitaire en France nous avons le
thermique qui n'est plus un système
immunitaire turbine à gaz ou même
charbon puisque si Cordemais est EDF
Saint-Avold et gazelle
et nous avons en ce qui concerne les
énergies renouvelables des milliers de
producteurs alors certains d'entre eux
sont très importants je pense aux
éoliennes d'engie ou de Total d'autres
sont des tout petits producteurs y
compris des particuliers qui ont des
panneaux photovoltaïques vous ne les
priverez plus de la liberté de produire
qui s'accompagnent évidemment d'une
décision d'investir j'ajoute je me
tourne vers mon excellent collègue
breviers qui a des convictions écolo que
je respecte mais que je ne partage pas
il a cependant la passion des économies
locales et circulaires qui passent en
particulier par des réseaux autonomes
qui ne seraient d'ailleurs pas
interconnecté ce qui entre nous et quand
même assez dangereux mais ce sont des
producteurs indépendants qui n'entendent
plus perdre leur indépendance c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous sommes obligés
de tenir compte d'un système
dans lequel la production électrique est
dominée par EDF et je m'en réjouis et je
m'en réjouis parce que c'est une
production de qualité mais ce n'est plus
une production monopolistique et c'est
la raison pour laquelle enedis comme RTE
doivent être indépendants pour qu'elles
offrent des services sur la base d'une
loyauté d'une équité dans les
traitements des producteurs indépendants
qui auront demain comme aujourd'hui le
droit de produire j'ajoute que tout cela
n'est quand même une construction
européenne dont la signature a été
donnée en 2002 à Barcelone par
l'ensemble un Conseil européen donc
l'ensemble des gouvernements je crois
que la France a été représentée par
Lionel Jospin qui n'est pas un dangereux
libéral
quelle est la vie du gouvernement
madame la Présidente donc même avis
défavorable sur ses amendements j'en
profite pour rappeler puisque je l'ai
indiqué dans ma discussion générale que
si le gouvernement dépense 10 milliards
d'argent des contribuables pour racheter
les parts manquantes d'EDF et en faire
une société détenue à 100% c'est pas
pour dans la foulée envisager quelques
sections quelques sessions pardon de
part du capital d'EDF quelle qu'elle
soit cela dit la priorité numéro 1 d'ODF
aujourd'hui c'est de restaurer sa
crédibilité financière et ça passe déjà
par des sessions d'actifs qui sont
évidemment des sessions d'actifs
marginaux qui sont déjà engagés à
hauteur de 3 millions d'euros donc si
autre amendement est adopté aujourd'hui
vous fragilisez la consolidation d'EDF
par ailleurs je le rappelle le nouveau
président directeur général d'EDF doit
remettre au gouvernement et vous aurez
évidemment toute la liberté pour
l'auditionner une nouvelle feuille de
route
dont les objectifs sont essentiellement
de trois types un restaurer les
capacités opérationnelles d'EDF donc il
faut le reconnaître qu'elles ont un peu
péché régulièrement
de la consolidation financière et trois
la manière dont les investissements
futurs et notamment la priorisation de
ces investissements vont être proposés à
l'actionnaire nous tous par la direction
et donc évidemment aujourd'hui s'engager
de manière totalement ferme à une
entreprise gelée voire même une
entreprise gelée y compris RTE enedis
puisque certains des amendements que
vous proposez aujourd'hui proposent de
geler le tout en total non conformité
avec le droit européen mais permettant
même en danger l'indépendance drte qui
elle est essentielle dans le schéma
actuel donc oui la vie est totalement
défavorable à ses amendements et j'en
profite pour rappeler au sénateur gay
dont je ne doute pas qu'il en est au
courant que les pertes d'anadys sont
rachetées au coût de la reine à EDF et
en aucun cas sur le marché à des
pré-exorbitants je vous enverrai des
textes
ils sont aujourd'hui achetés au prix de
l'arène que vous la reine que vous
critiquez jour et nuit alors qu'elle
permet aujourd'hui non mais parlons de
la reine une seconde alors même si c'est
pas tout à fait l'objet de votre
amendement la reine aujourd'hui est
permet aux industriels français d'être
compétitif grâce à une énergie payée en
gros au prix coûtant sur des
investissements qui ont été payés par la
présentation par l'état français par la
nation depuis 70 ans il va falloir le
remplacer ce dispositif mais j'espère
qu'on trouvera un dispositif qui
permettra encore de réindustrialiser la
France plutôt que de la
désindustrialiser avis défavorable sur
ces trois ou quatre amendements merci
pour une explication de vote
et merci madame la Présidente
j'écoute attentivement le ministre moi
je voudrais savoir peut-être pourra-t-il
nous nous le dire si ce qui a été
demandé au nouveau PDG de d'EDF
correspond à ce que nous proposons dans
cette amendement en matière de
production
de développements
d'exploitation et de maintenance de
prestations de services énergétique de
transport etc voilà et dans le respect
contrairement à ce qui vient d'être dit
stricte du droit européen notamment
concernant RTE et enedis voilà parce que
cette c'est l'intention de de cet
amendement et je pense que ça ça
justifie votre favorable donc encore une
fois dans le cadre d'un groupement
public unifié et d'un capital préservé
et je et je redis ici que la question
des 2% de capital des salariés
est un problème majeur monsieur le
ministre si vous pouviez nous répondre
là-dessus ça serait très très très
utile pour pour nous merci Monsieur gay
merci Madame la président monsieur le
ministre je répondrai pas sur la reine
puisque je crois qu'il y a un amendement
qui viendra
sur le droit européen juste parce qu'on
a déjà ce débat depuis deux ans tout le
monde s'est en train de s'asseoir sur le
droit européen sauf nous les Portugais
les Espagnols nous ont montré la voix
sur le marché européen en obtenant une
dérogation les Allemands eux ils ont pas
besoin ils nous ont encore tordu le bras
il y a qu'un jour et donc nous avons
signé une réformète du marché européen
qui continue à avantager l'industrie
allemande à notre détriment et il
s'assoit sur le droit européen à chaque
fois qu'ils en ont besoin pour en
réalité protéger leur industrie ça a
l'air de déranger personne mais par
contre nous il faut absolument rester
dans les clous du Grand repère nous
sommes les derniers à le faire moi c'est
pas grave si ça vous fait plaisir mais
si c'est ça la réalité et la réforme du
marché européen ici personne me dira les
uns dans les yeux quelle sera favorable
à l'industrie française personne peut
m'expliquer ça et je finis par vous dire
que madame lavard vous a posé une
question
qui était extrêmement intéressante 60
milliards de dettes et vous le dites le
nouveau PDG lucrémont va devoir vous
rendre une feuille de route sur savoir
comment se désendetter et évidemment
comment investir donc vous êtes
responsable en partie puisque la reine
plus ça a coûté 8 milliards 4 l'an
dernier quand même et donc on pourra
continuer à biberonner les acteurs
alternatifs ça continue à dépecer en
réalité EDF et j'y reviendrai a
racketter les usagers mais comment ils
vont se désentêter de 60 milliards
est-ce que une des propositions sera de
accélérer la session d'actifs et
notamment on commencera par les actifs
qui rapporteront le plus Dalkia enedis
c'est ça la réalité je vous remercie
madame la présidente monsieur Lurel
merci madame la Présidente j'aimerais
que monsieur le ministre vous puissiez
répondre à la question de mon collègue
montaugier sur la présence
salariés de la participation et de
l'actionnariat des salariés deuxième
chose vous avez invoqué les avantages de
la reine bien sûr qu'il y a qu'il y en a
mais moi j'ai une autre lecture
une autre lecture sur ce que veut dire
doit absorber et payer premièrement
acheter des renouvelables qui sont très
largement subventionnés et qui sont
intermittents mais il faut le faire et
revendre au prix du marché ensuite
mettre 25% de l'énergie nucléaire
historique sur le marché à 42 euros tout
ça c'est EDF qui accepte ça et je suis
pas sûr que ça profite que c'était car
de compétitivité que nous avons avec
cette composante historique amorti et
bien profite aujourd'hui à l'industrie
française et à la nation
il n'y a plus d'explication de vote nous
allons donc passer au deuxième scrutin
public sur d'abord sur l'amendement
numéro 3 je rappelle que cet amendement
reçu un avis défavorable de la
commission et du gouvernement le scrutin
est ouvert
et non non
merci
vote en 343 exprimé 339 pour 100 contre
239 il y a deux autres scrutins
publiques qui sont les amendements ne
fait 10 est-ce que tout le monde serait
d'accord pour qu'on considère que c'est
le même vote
et ensuite nous avons monsieur guest ça
va être un amendement 14 il est
peut-être pas au tableau mais je vous le
l'indique un moment 14 sur l'article 2
j'ai pas compris
en 10 secondes puisque nous c'est un
amendement de repli puisque nous avons
perdu le débat sur la Renault
nationalisation nous n'aurons pas les
pics au moins que comme la Compagnie
nationale du Rhône cela ne reste pas une
SA mais une société anonyme au moins
d'intérêt général voilà ce que nous
demandons je vous remercie merci quelle
est la vie de la Commission sur cet
amendement
commission n'a pas adopté cet amendement
donc c'est un avis défavorable j'imagine
monsieur le ministre
ma vie défavorable
il y a encore un scrutin public sur cet
amendement on fait comme on a fait il y
a un instant c'est le même vote
ok même votre monde est d'accord donc il
n'est pas adopté il y a un amendement 19
d'une gouvernement
la présidence est amendement me permet
d'évoquer le sujet de l'actionnaire un
salarié évoqué dans leur discussion
générale ou dans la discussion
d'amendement par un certain nombre des
sénateurs et des sénatrices ici présente
nous proposons
[Musique]
je dirais de rendre possible de
l'actionnariat salarié au sein de
l'entreprise EDF même si pour être très
clair nous ne jugeons cette absolument
ni souhaitable ni même envisageable à
très court terme pourquoi parce qu'on
est justement en train de racheter 100%
du capital pour restaurer la capacité
financière de l'entreprise la capacité
par non opérationnelle et sa capacité à
investir donc non seulement faire ce
genre d'opération aujourd'hui c'est sans
doute pas à faire un cadeau salarié
alors que la rédaction actuelle nous y
forcerait dès le premier janvier 2024
les forces restent sans doute à faire
une très mauvaise opération financière
mais au-delà serait évidemment
totalement anachronique alors qu'on est
exactement en train de faire le
contraire c'est à dire de racheter les
minoritaires y compris certains
d'ailleurs détenus dans le cadre de
l'action salarié vous le savez
aujourd'hui l'État détient déjà 90% du
capital et pourrait légalement racheter
les 10% restants du fait d'un certain
nombre de recours qui ont été déposés
l'État le gouvernement s'est engagé à
attendre que ces recours soit jugés vous
l'avez dit madame la sénatrice début
mais avant
au cas où ces recours serait rejetées de
procéder à l'acquisition de la totalité
du capital vous avez voté dans l'article
1 le fait que l'État doit être tiers
100% du capital et vous nous demandiez
pourquoi cet amendement était
indispensable aujourd'hui parce que du
fait de cet article 1 si jamais nous
souhaitions si jamais l'entreprise
souhaitait si jamais l'actionnaire
acceptait de procéder à la mise en place
d'un dispositif d'actionnaires salariés
en 2024 2025 ou 2026 ça serait tout
simplement impossible du fait de
l'article 1 que vous avez voté c'est
pour ça c'est la raison pour laquelle
cet amendement que nous proposons
aujourd'hui au Sénat rend la possibilité
ouverte
sont nécessairement un passage au
Parlement à la direction de proposer un
programme d'actionnaire un salarié
évidemment sans obligation d'autant une
durée pour laisser à l'entreprise le
temps de je dirais remettre en forme
avant d'y procéder merci David la
commission sur cet amendement du
Gouvernement
[Musique]
madame la Présidente Michel collègue la
Commission a exprimé un avis de sagesse
parce que cette affaire est en effet
très difficile et très sensible
nous avons un immense respect pour
l'entreprise EDF ce qui nous a conduit à
soutenir un amendement de notre collègue
Victorin Lurel qui fait d'EDF et on
retrouve dans le texte de la commission
une entreprise d'intérêt national ça n'a
pas de signification juridique autre que
de reconnaître que la communauté des
salariés dans l'histoire de déesse a
bien fait son travail
82000 salariés en seins salariés sont
été actionnés ou sont actionnaires de DF
aujourd'hui c'est l'expression d'un
engagement dans leur entreprise qui
conforte cette image de communauté c'est
la raison pour laquelle la Commission
souhaitait et avait proposé un texte qui
donnait cette possibilité en l'encadrant
dans une période courte et c'est le
problème de la période courte qui
apparaît avec force madame l'avare l'a
fait valoir dans le débat en commission
nous avons trop d'inconnus celles que
j'ai évoquées à la tribune sur l'avenir
du marché lannir de l'organisation le
marché de l'énergie électrique je suis
très optimiste il est il sera
nécessairement en croissance parce que
la décarbonation de notre société passe
par l'électricité donc je n'ai
simplement aucun doute sur le fait qu'il
nous faudra produire de plus en plus
d'électricité et que l'entreprise qui a
le bénéfices de l'expérience de plus de
50 ans de 58 réacteurs nucléaires et
quand même mieux placé que n'importe
quel autre entreprise pour conquérir des
positions nouvelles fortes mais ce n'est
pas encore dans un cadre clair et donc
nous avons besoin de savoir si il y aura
des contrats d'achat de long terme
motorisés s'il y aura des contrats par
différents s'il y aura la possibilité
d'acheter des parts de centrales
nucléaires pour avoir des droits de
tirage comme excelsium en profite je
sais de quoi je parle je l'ai mis en
place comme ministre de l'Industrie au
siècle précédent donc nous avons toute
une série de questions qui méritent
d'obtenir des réponses avant que
d'engager l'économie des salariés dans
ce qui reste toujours une aventure vous
savez très bien que lorsque l'on fait de
la publicité pour une offre de public de
voilà on dit
les les performances passées n'engagent
pas l'avenir et donc pour protéger les
salariés nous souhaitons
sagesse sagesse positive à l'égard de
l'amendement du Gouvernement sur
rapporteur je vais vous surveiller
attentivement
mais c'est le drame de ma fonction
si on en est si on parle de drame le
mien est terrible aussi vous savez
monsieur moto g vous avez merci madame
la Présidente nous n'avons pas eu
d'explication claire du ministre sur les
conséquences juridiques de cet
amendement
sur les concessions hydrauliques dans le
cadre européen
l'analyse que nous en faisons c'est
qu'avec cette mesure vous lancez une
torpille contre le groupe EDF je pèse
mes mots vous allez devoir mais je pense
que c'est peut-être votre intention
première détacher l'hydraulique du
groupe EDF donc démanteler et ce sera le
commencement peut-être de la fin à
l'instar de ce qui s'est passé pour
l'entreprise nationale qui était Gaz de
France à une époque alors voilà cela
nous laisse pas de de nous inquiéter ce
débat est crucial s'il reste une part de
capital autre que d'État
au sein du groupe
on va être vous allez être confronté à
cette question là je pense que les
territoires vont peu apprécier de voir
mis en concurrence peut-être par
obligation les concessions hydrauliques
sur le territoire national est-ce
qu’encore une fois vous pouvez nous
préciser votre analyse par rapport à ce
point extrêmement important merci
moi aussi j'ai des questions pour
Monsieur ministre que j'avoue que son
explication de m'a pas vraiment
convaincu ou rassuré et je reste
toujours très sceptique quand je lis
l'exposé des motifs de cet amendement
qui dit quand même que donc l'amendement
vise à ce que les anciens salariés
pourront donc être actionnaires d'EDF de
sorte à ce que les salariés du groupe ne
soient pas forcés de vendre leur titre
lors du départ de l'entreprise mais
enfin ce que je ne crois pas c'est que
vous venez de nous réexpliquer que vous
allez monter à 100% du capital donc à un
moment ils ont déjà vendu leur titre ils
peuvent toujours être dans l'entreprise
et donc l'exposé des motifs semble dire
qu'ils ont encore ces titres et qu'il ne
seraient pas forcé de les vendre au
moment où ils partent alors je sais il y
a quelque chose qui est pas très clair
et c'est toute la procédure de mise en
oeuvre en fait c'est soit l'État détient
100% du capital et on le dit et ça peut
permettre et pour tout un tas de raisons
que j'ai exposé tout à l'heure avoir sa
pertinence notamment pour venir
permettre le financement de ces
investissements conséquents qui ne vont
pas permettre le financement de
dividende soit on dit qu'effectivement
on veut apporter quelque chose assez
salarié qui ont fait l'histoire du
groupe qui ont fait l'histoire de notre
politique
énergétique et notre notamment notre
politique nucléaire mais à ce moment-là
il faut que ce soit clair pour eux et là
j'avoue que ça ne l'est pas
bien je vais donc monsieur le ministre
vous souhaiter répondre
vous le pouvez je comprends que les
débats doivent s'accélérer mais un je
enfin le fait de rendre l'actionnariat
salarié optionnel ou obligatoire tel
qu'il est aujourd'hui prévu dans la
rédaction de la commission nous
changeons rien aux questions que vous
vous posez monsieur le sénateur donc on
va s'assurer que j'ai bien compris votre
question et si vous m'y autorisez on
répondra par écrit mais le fait que
l'actionnaire soit optionnel ou ou
obligatoire à mon avis ne change rien
les débats qu'on a par ailleurs sur les
concessions hydrauliques sur lesquelles
il faut évidemment qu'on soit
extrêmement ferme donc je vais essayer
de clarifier effectivement
nous achetons 100% du capital point et
donc si le jugement du tribunal des
muets est conforme à ce à quoi on
s'attend on aura dans la foulée la
capacité d'acheter les 5% du capital
restant l'état détiendra 100% du capital
point si dans deux ans trois ans quatre
ans cinq ans la situation de
l'entreprise est dans une meilleure
situation on l'autorise par cet
amendement éventuellement à envisager et
à mettre en œuvre un accord
d'actionnariat salarié sans avoir à
repasser par le Parlement
et cet accord d'actionnariat salarié
comme c'était le cas dans l'accord
précédent permet à la fois de
aux salariés d'acheter des actions du
groupe et de les détenir et de les
conserver
ultérieurement au cas où il quitterait
le groupe par exemple pour prendre leur
retraite donc c'est juste pour
reproduire en avant des dispositions qui
existaient d'ores et déjà dans la corde
actionnaires salarié aujourd'hui et
c'est en aucun cas évidemment l'idée de
prolonger les actions détenues
aujourd'hui par des salariés au-delà de
l'achat qui je le confirme passera bien
à 100% du capital jusqu'à jusqu'à ce
qu'on en décide autrement dans le cadre
de la gestion de l'entreprise et dans le
cadre d'un accord d'actionnaire un
salarié merci Monsieur gay
merci madame la Présidente comme quoi
l'actionnariat salarié c'est un peu plus
compliqué que ce qu'on nous vend tous
les jours puisque a priori pour vous ça
devrait même remplacer le salaire
intéressement participation à qui on a
salarié c'est bon pour vous et les
salaires pas du tout
cette affaire d'actionnariat salariés
sur EDF on va les défendre parce que
c'est une compas où ça Sion il faut se
rappeler l'histoire c'est pas historique
l'action derrière le salarié chez EDF ça
a commencé en 2005 lorsque vous avez
décidé d'ouvrir au capital et donc
c'était en réalité une compensation pour
les salariés 130 000 à l'époque sont
devenus actionnaires salariés et ils
auront perdu de l'argent parce que ceux
qui ont racheté le titre à 30 euros et
qui seront obligés de le revendre à 11
ou 12 euros auront bien perdu de
l'argent et donc là vous expliquer et
c'est pour ça qu'il vous aura attaqué
notamment sur une question et les
dernières décisions que vous avez prises
notamment les 20 Tera watts
supplémentaires qu'on fait perdre 8
milliards quatre et qu'on fait baisser
en réalité le prix de l'action au moment
où il est sorti en bourse et c'est pour
ça que vous allez pouvoir le racheter
entre 11 et 12 euros donc là vous nous
expliquez vous êtes en capacité en
quelque sorte de spolier les
actionnaires salariés aujourd'hui vous
allez reprendre 100% et peut-être demain
vous allez le reposer
de redevenir actionnaire salarié il y
aura un problème quand même ce ministre
vous voyez bien quand même personne ne
comprend rien à ce que vous êtes en
train de faire je vous remercie merci
donc sur cet amendement du gouvernement
qui a Monsieur kevenevet merci Madame la
président de Monsieur le Ministre bon
effectivement comme je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure dans la discussion générale le
groupe de l'Union centriste est
particulièrement attaché à ce que il y
ait le développement de l'actionnaire
salarié qui est aussi des notions de
partage de la valeur et c'est vrai que
le les propositions du rapporteur nous
semblait empruntent de bon sens compte
tenu de la discussion qui vient
d'évoquer le groupe va s'abstenir
merci donc sur cet amendement du
gouvernement qui a reçu un avis de
sagesse de la Commission et pour lequel
il y a une demande de scrutin public
nous allons procéder au scrutin public
qui est à cet instant est ouvert voilà
tout le monde a voté le scrutin est donc
l'eau
alors vote en 343 exprimé 209 pour 183
contre 26 le Sénat a donc adopté nous
avons maintenant un amendement
ah pardon j'ai failli zapper le vote sur
l'article
article de demande de scrutin public
également
on va le faire
un public sur l'article là
le scrutin est ouvert
plus personne ne demande à voter le
scrutin est donc clos
votre en 343 exprimé 315 pour
216,99 le Sénat a adopté nous passons
maintenant à l'amendement numéro 18
monsieur moto G
merci
jaunes dans cette émission nous en
appelons au renforcement de notre
souveraineté nationale au sens premier
du terme il s'agit de doter au souverain
donc à notre peuple la possibilité par
le vote de ses représentants de décider
des questions et sujets qui engagent la
vie de la nation depuis près de 80 ans
EDF a été au cœur de la performance
économique de la France nous devons à
cette entreprise et aux générations de
salariés qui se sont succédés une part
importante de la compétitivité de notre
industrie et plus largement de notre
économie c'est encore vrai aujourd'hui
malgré les difficultés provoquées qui
ont été évoquées par la mise en place du
marché européen dont beaucoup de
consommateurs quel que soit leur taille
peine d'avoir les effets positifs
induits EDF pour les activités de cœur
de métier décritent cet amendement doit
être un levier fort d'amélioration de la
compétitivité nationale dans le contexte
de transition énergétique et climatique
que nous devons collectivement réussir
c'est pour cela que le Parlement aussi
doit être saisi de tout sujet de
réorganisation concernant EDF
amendement quelle est la ville de la
Commission
la commission est défavorable madame la
Présidente pourquoi parce que il
n'appartient pas au législateur de
diriger au quotidien une société
nationale une société nationalisée un
épique chacun fait son métier et le
parlementaire contre le gouvernement
quelle est la vie du gouvernement mais
ma vie monsieur le ministre
voilà scrutin public sur cet amendement
double avis défavorable on va le voter
on va faire procéder au scrutin public
est-ce que tu as est ouvert
plus personne ne demande à votre thé le
scrutin est clou voici les résultats du
scrutin votre en 343 exprimer 339 pour
100 contre 239 le Sénat n'a pas adopté
l'amendement numéro 4 de monsieur Lurel
c'est vous qui présentez
il s'agit de rétablir dans son texte
original originel
la
l'évaluation donc le rachat de
l'entreprise EDF un peu à l'instar de
ceux qui avaient été fait en 46 par une
instance commission administrative
nationale d'évaluation
présidée par
des fonctionnaires indépendants nous
pensons nous que l'offre publique
d'achat simplifié
n'aboutira pas contrairement à ce que
moi j'ai pu entendre ici il y a quelques
certitudes comme si nous maîtrisions les
délais judiciaires de la cour d'appel de
Paris et du Conseil d'État mais moi j'en
suis pas sûr
d'autant plus qu'il y a des possibilités
de recours ultime d'appels de cassation
ce n'est pas évident donc on a une loi
de nationalisation qui est peut-être
aubaine pour le gouvernement
apparaît au plus mauvais au plus pressé
au cas où et donc nous vous demandons de
voter cet amendement pour rétablir le
principe d'une nationalisation de DF
quelle est l'avis de la commission sur
cet amendement
mission n'est pas favorable puisque
l'article premier était supprimé
avis du gouvernement
[Musique]
monsieur Capu vous voulez une
explication de votre je crois
merci madame la Présidente je peux
intervenu sur les précédents mais je
voulais quand même rappeler je l'ai dit
lors de la discussion générale que si
EDF est dans la situation qui est la
sienne ça n'est pas parce que ça n'était
pas une entreprise nationale c'est
on peut pas reprocher à l'entreprise
privée EDF d'être dans la situation dans
laquelle nous sommes aujourd'hui EDF est
dans sa situation uniquement parce que
la filière nucléaire a été malmené par
des gouvernements socialistes sous
l'influence de groupes écologistes et
c'est aujourd'hui c'est la raison pour
laquelle le nucléaire est dans la
situation actuelle donc je pense qu'il
faut quand même le rappeler il y a une
prise de conscience qui est tout à fait
salvatrice d'une très grande majorité
des français et même des groupes
politiques qui qui forment la gauche
aujourd'hui et qui prennent conscience
que si on veut vraiment lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique il faut une
énergie décarbonée et donc il faut
relancer le nucléaire mais ça n'est pas
parce que ça n'était pas une entreprise
nationale que EDF se trouve dans la
situation qui est la sienne aujourd'hui
je pense qu'il est bon de le rappeler
est-ce qu'on pourrait imaginer que sur
cet amendement de rétablissement de
l'article 3 dans la version initiale on
est le même vote que sur l'article sur
les amendements de rétablissement de
l'article 1
ce qui nous épargnerait ce côté un
public qui a été demandé et donc on
considérait que le Sénat n'a pas à
adopter l'amendement avant de moi
l'article 3 bis monsieur gay pour deux
amendements vous pouvez présenter les
deux en même temps enfin
ok si vous êtes d'accord j'en suis
totalement d'accord donc c'est
trois attendez madame la
rtigue a été supprimé donc il y a pas de
vote sur l'article il y a plus
d'articles
on m'a voté la main on a voté
l'amendement de rétablissement il n'a
pas été adopté donc il y a plus
d'article
propose donc les trois amendements qui
proposent le retour au tarif réglementé
le premier sur le mode de calcul les le
deuxième pour le retour au tarif
réglementé pour toutes les collectivités
et les TPE PME et le dernier un
amendement de repli pour les
collectivités juste sur les TRV et la
reine parce qu'il y a évidemment un lien
de cause à effet d'ailleurs je pense que
il faudra regarder sur les 60 milliards
d'endettement jusqu'à réellement coûté
la reine qui a été votée en 2010 dans le
cadre de la loi normes et je crois pas
que c'était un gouvernement socialiste à
l'époque
non il y a une vraie question autour de
la reine et pour répondre tout à l'heure
à l'interpellation de monsieur le
rapporteur c'est vrai qu'il y a des
acteurs alternatifs qui produisent mais
sur les 90 aujourd'hui il y en a deux
véritables c'est engie et total énergie
tout le reste sont des facturateurs et
sont en réalité des suceurs de sang
d'EDF permettez-moi de le dire comme ça
et donc s'il n'y avait pas et si on
suspendait la reine c'est 88 acteurs
alternatifs tomberaient c'est comme ça
et d'ailleurs pour vous dire il n'y a
pas que le groupe communiste ou Fabien
geckel de demande j'ai vu que le
rapporteur monsieur Armand qui député
Renaissance demande la suspension très
rapide de la reine vous voyez donc quand
il y a des gens qui commencent à
travailler sur la question il sera en
compte de l'inertie de ce système et il
ne demande pas le rénover il demande à
le suspendre et sur le retour au tarif
réglementé juste une question parce que
les gens ne doivent savoir ça c'est
qu'aujourd'hui plus il y a d'arènes
moins il y a des traitements et donc
c'est vrai que les acteurs alternatifs
aujourd'hui ils doivent aller se fournir
pour 70% sur la reine à 40 euros et
après en réalité sur le marché donc
comme le prix à dévisser cette année ils
ont été des fois 200-300 400 500 euros
de mégawattheure avec un pic tout le
monde connaît au mois d'août à 1200 mais
en réalité
aujourd'hui nous avons un problème c'est
que depuis cinq ans ce n'est pas
l'empilement des coûts et le coût réel
c'est que on prend en compte pour
l'augmentation du tarif légalementé la
partie du taux des traitements pour les
acteurs alternatifs qui doivent aller se
fournir sur le marché et donc en réalité
on ne peut plus avec le tarif le
commenté le coût réel de l'énergie on
paye en réalité aujourd'hui les
dividendes des actionnaires des acteurs
alternatifs c'est ça la réalité et donc
le tarif réglementé il augmente non pas
sur les coûts réels mais sur cette part
décrètement et donc sur le trading du
marché c'est ça la réalité depuis 5 ans
et c'est pour ça que ça dévisse et c'est
pour ça que le tarif réglementé il a
augmenté en réalité beaucoup ces deux
dernières années mais bien avant depuis
2017 il ne cesse d'augmenter tous les
six mois donc il faut en revenir sur un
tarif réglementé qui s'applique sur les
coûts et il faut en finir avec la reine
qui raquette d'un côté EDF et qui
raquette aussi les usagers c'est ça la
réalité voilà je vous remercie et donc
j'ai présenté les trois en même temps
merci bien monsieur le rapporteur va
donner son avis sur les trois en même
temps
madame la Présidente la commission n'est
pas favorable ces trois amendements
parce qu'ils sont en opposition avec ce
que nous avons établi d'accord accords
gouvernementaux transposé en droit en
français et en particulier dans le code
de l'énergie sur la capacité d'ouvrir
les trve à l'ensemble des consommateurs
sont justiciables de dtave les
résidentiels particuliers et les
professionnels dès lors des
professionnels dès lors qu'ils ont moins
de 10 salariés moins de 2 millions de
chiffre d'affaires alors on a envie
d'aider tout le monde sauf que c'est
assez coûteux j'ai cru comprendre et
d'autre alors ça c'est un premier
problème nous serions en contradiction
avec les règles européennes ensuite on
est fait on irait subventionné on irait
casser des contrats qui sont établis
actuellement entre des entreprises et
des
les fournisseurs alternatifs privés qui
seraient fondé à dire puisque la loi
nous oblige à prendre en charge des
terres hors EDF évidemment des tervu
d'alternative à ce moment-là ils sont
retournés faire le gouvernement en
disant puisque vous nous Cassez des
contrats où on gagnait notre vie pour
nous obliger à vendre moins cher ensuite
on va voir ce que veut dire moins cher
remboursez-nous alors là ça coûterait
bonbon et puis troisième remarque le
est calculé par la creux par un
empilement et par un jeu assez complexe
en effet de lissage dans le temps et
nous ne pourrions avoir ces prix que
dans une dans une perspective assez
longue madame l'avare qui connaît mieux
le sujet que moi pourraient expliquer il
faut
un recul
d'environ 12 mois je crois pour pouvoir
établir des terres nouveaux donc on est
dans un système qui est à peu près non
praticable et c'est la raison pour
laquelle je propose de se borner à
limiter au 36 kVA à faire supprimer les
36 kVA dans le cadre de l'Europe
monsieur le ministre votre avis sur ces
trois amendements un avis similaire
j'aimerais rajouter que cette article en
fait a été adoptée en commission lors de
l'examen à l'Assemblée nationale
l'article qui généralisait le TRV à tous
les à tous les consommateurs
vous n'y êtes pour rien vous n'en avez
hérité mais il reste pour nous un casier
un cavalier total à cette proposition de
loi et sans rapport si je puis
m'exprimer ainsi avec le schmilblick
cela dit il est là aujourd'hui il vous
est arrivé comme tel il faut donc qu'on
en discute et c'est vrai que vous avez
limité son coût en en limitant les faits
au TPE en disant voilà c'est les TPE
toutes les TPE qu'elles soient en fait
consommatrices individuelle comme vous
et moi ou qu'elle soit consommatrice
intensive comme certaines boulangers
dont on a beaucoup parlé j'en comprends
j'en comprends la logique c'est moins
coûteux évidemment que ce qu'avait voté
l'assemblée alors c'est vrai qu'il y a
de la certitude sur le coup tout
simplement parce que ce type de
dispositif il est exposé au marché et
que son coût varie toutes les semaines
en fonction du prix de marché c'est
d'ailleurs un de ces dangers
c'est que vous exposez alors soit les
finances d'EDF au choix
si EDF qui paye soit les finances de
l'État un coup de marché qui lui on l'a
vu depuis un an et demi est extrêmement
volatile
et donc on décidant de supprimer le
plafond du RV alors soit pour toutes les
entreprises de l'ordre de 20 milliards
j'avais dit 18 et pourquoi j'avais dit
18 à l'époque parce que l'écart entre le
prix de marché
quand j'étais à l'Assemblée nationale et
l'écart du TRV étaient de l'ordre de 200
euros le mégawatts pour une consommation
de l'ensemble des entreprises concernées
par l'amendement brun de l'ordre de
santerawatts donc on arrivait à 20
milliards 18 pour être précis
aujourd'hui votre amendement coûte moins
cher pour deux raisons d'abord ce que
vous en limitez l'impact
on est sur une consommation de l'ordre
de 20 terawatts et puis l'écart a lui
aussi baissé parce que le prix de marché
avait baissé donc aujourd'hui votre
amendement il coûte à peu près un
milliard d'euros 50 euros d'écart entre
le TRV et le prix de marché pour à peu
près 21 watts mais si demain ou
après-demain le prix de marché explose
et ben il coûtera 2 3 4 5 6 7 milliards
d'euros et il faudra qu'on en assume les
conséquences soit directement sur les
comptes d'EDF quand on souhaite
aujourd'hui tous qu'ils soient préservés
soit sur les comptes de l'État dont on
reconnaîtra tous je pense qui sont quand
même pas dans un état fantastique c'est
les raisons pour laquelle moi j'étais le
gouvernement était défavorable à
l'ensemble de cette généralisation du
TRV qu'on y a substituer des aides éner
qui certes ont été critiqués mais dont
il faut reconnaître aujourd'hui qu'elle
fonctionne on a des pensées à peu près
de 150 millions d'euros sur notre notre
bouclier tarifaire on a dépendant sur
les sur le guichet ouvert depuis janvier
on a dépensé entre 50 et 80 milliards
d'euros sur le bouclier tarifaire on a
aujourd'hui beaucoup aidés les ménages
beaucoup aidés les entreprises y compris
les énergo intensives on va continuer à
le faire je préfère qu'on le fasse dans
le cadre actuel que dans le cadre de cet
article merci
Monsieur Durel pour une explication de
vote
je tenais à répondre sur un point un
autre excellent Capu en
2000 en 96 c'était pas des socialistes
c'était une directive en 2003 c'était
encore une directive c'était pas nous en
2009 c'était pas nous en 2010 la loi
nomme qui met en place trois dispositifs
dont la reine le mécanisme de capacité
et des TRV c'était pas nous c'était bien
il me semble de ta couleur politique
donc que ce soit partagé on le sait bien
et que EDF est aujourd'hui les problèmes
et depuis toujours il faut revoir le
système lui-même et en particulier les
marchés électriques en Europe il faut
avoir le courage de dire ici et ailleurs
que dans la stratégie qui a été adoptée
contrairement à ce qui a été fait depuis
46 en 74 par Messmer aujourd'hui on est
tributeur est soumis à l'Allemagne et à
d'autres concurrents il faut le dire
l'avantage que nous avions en nucléaire
profite à d'autres et on n'ose pas on
vient de perdre mon combat taxonomie on
vient de dire que les réacteurs
classiques ne seront pas intégrés et ne
recevront pas un subventionnement un
public alors que c'était un combat
homérique et bien aujourd'hui c'est un
combat d'arrière garde que nous
conduisons et c'est la raison pour
laquelle faire de dire une entreprise
nationale intégrée verticale publique et
unifié était une urgence mobilisatrice
pour les Français que nous sommes
si la parole est maintenant à Monsieur
sont
je profite de votre intervention ce que
j'ai bien entendu et je vais je veux
bien me faire confirmer ce que vous avez
évoqué sur TRV tarif de marché et la
grande fluctuation vous avez évoqué les
boulangers mais il y a malheureusement
pas que et donc je pense qu'il est
important d'envoyer un message
au public concerné puisque un certain
nombre de fournisseurs à l'automne
dernier ont écrit alors abonnés en
disant écoutez on peut plus tenir les
tarifs
que le qui nous liait de manière
contractuelle en voler des prix ça a été
multiplié parfois par 5 6 7 8 et puis
aujourd'hui donc à ce moment-là il
aurait été proposé de signer de nouveaux
contrats parfois contrariée
dont aujourd'hui l'opérateur dit
lui-même a mais maintenant je ne peux
plus y toucher
je le dis parce que comme il se trouve
que ce fournisseur a trois lettres dont
on parle beaucoup aujourd'hui
il va y avoir besoin d'une chose on
clarifie la situation d'abord l'état
aura la main et à défaut vous l'avez dit
soit l'opérateur le fournisseur
revoit ces conditions on nous dit que
c'est pas possible j'entends soit l'état
viendra en compensation mais il faut le
dire aujourd'hui parce que derrière il y
a des entreprises vous le savez et je
pense que l'État a un message envoyé
pour garantir un traitement je dirais
équitable des situations puisque cette
situation elle est provoquée en tant
qu'elle est étrangère aux entreprises
voilà monsieur le ministre que je
voulais appeler votre attention sur ce
sujet qui est un sujet majeur
viens maintenant la parole est à
Monsieur manteau j'ai
merci
que de deux amendements ont été
déclarés irrecevable au titre de
l'article 45 relatif à la reine nous
souhaitions et nous pensons qu'il est
souhaitable de limiter le volume d'arène
à sentir à water d'une part et d'autre
part de permettre le passage de 42 euros
à 49,5 euros EDF a besoin de ressources
financières pour faire face à ces
besoins d'investissement en particulier
et depuis la loi d'août 2022 et la vie
du Conseil d'État sur la nécessité ou
pas de notifier cette évolution de prix
à l'Union européenne voilà il est
possible il est possible de procéder à
cette à cette révision
c'est absolument nécessaire et il aurait
été intéressant de savoir quand le
gouvernement va procéder à cela
en théorie il est possible depuis le 1er
janvier 2023 je vous remercie monsieur
Capu
merci Madame
ok mon collègurel je partage avec lui en
revanche le fait que on a besoin d'une
filière nucléaire brillante qui permette
même de céder de l'électricité à nos
voisins et là-dessus nous sommes en
accord je voulais revenir sur ces trois
rendements et plus globalement sur
l'article 3 bis évidemment on ne peut
qu'être favorable dans le principe à
l'extension de du tarif réglementé c'est
difficile d'être contre cependant
d'un autre côté faut quand même aussi
être responsable
particulièrement pour les membres de la
commission des finances c'est quand même
de l'argent public évidemment on peut
étendre à tout le monde le tarif
réglementé nous y sommes tous favorables
mais derrière ce sont les finances
publiques qui sont mises en cause et
donc je voudrais formuler trois
remarques à ce stade certaines que j'ai
déjà formulé lors de la commission des
finances la première et le ministre
vient de le dire
cette cet article 3bis ne figurerait pas
dans le texte social alors les auteurs
font ce qu'ils veulent ils n'en reste
pas moins que ça ressemble fortement à
un cavalier législatif qui n'avait rien
à voir avec le texte initial relatif à
la nationalisation de DF deuxième
remarque là-dessus nous avons déjà eu
des échanges en commission de finances
avec le président de la commission des
finances il est incontestable que quel
que soit le payeur et le ministre vient
de le dire au final c'est le
contribuable qui paiera et donc
incontestablement même si pour des
raisons de procédure on peut plaider le
contraire incontestablement cet article
aurait dû être frappé de l'article 40 et
il aurait dû être jugé il recevable de
façon incontestable puisqu'il grève
nécessairement les finances publiques et
ma troisième remarque découle des deux
premières cet article 3 bis n'a rien à
faire ici il devrait plutôt s'intégrer
dans un PLF afin que nous puissions
avoir une étude d'impact sérieux sur le
coup de cette mesure
merci Madame la prison monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues on est
d'accord que les tarifs réglementés
ça a existait pendant 50 ans pour tout
le monde
résidentiel entreprise collectivités
tout le monde y avait accès ça marchait
plutôt bien
j'ai jamais vu personne s'en plaindre à
l'époque
premièrement deuxième chose monsieur le
rapporteur j'ai répondu nous dire c'est
les règles européennes oui mais tout le
monde dirait déroge tout le monde
demande des dérogations pourquoi nous
nous demandons pas une dérogation pour
protéger nos collectivités nos petites
entreprises en leur permettant le tarif
réglementé par leur imposant s'il y a
des collectivités des entreprises qui
souhaitent rester dans des contrats à
marcher libre tant mieux pour elle mais
celle qui voit leur facture exploser on
est tous élus de départements vous citez
les commerçants les boulangers des
collectivités et on est qu'au début de
la crise ça va encore durer deux ans et
demi les factures vont continuer à
pleuvoir troisième problème c'est le
Ministre et où il va falloir que quand
même un moment donné quelque part au 30
juin
5 millions de personnes n'auront pu
accès au tarif réglementé du gaz les
particuliers en pleine crise du gaz
est-ce que nous allons laisser faire
cette chose ou pas est-ce que nous nous
allons quand même prendre une initiative
ou parlementaire au gouvernemental pour
les prolonger en pleine crise ou est-ce
qu'on va tout et tous les laisser sans
foncer sur le prix du marché il faudra
répondre et puis dernière chose monsieur
le ministre
vous dites ça coûte cher certes quand on
a proposé le retour au tarif réglementé
pour toutes les collectivités on départ
on nous a dit 60 milliards et quand il y
a une étude 3 milliards et demi 3
milliards et demi et vous l'avez dit
combien en bouclier tarifaire sécurité
filet de sécurité arène supplémentaire
rien que l'an dernier avec les trous de
la raquette 50 à 80 milliards donc 3
milliards et demi pour le retour au
tarif réglementé et 50 à 80 milliards
que vous avez jeté à la poubelle et
donner aux acteurs alternatifs voilà la
réalité
je me suis brouillé
merci madame la Présidente bon moi je
voterai avec mon groupe c'est
propositions dont j'admets qui auraient
leur place dans un PLF très volontiers
mais je voulais en profiter aussi pour
répondre à mon collègue
qui nous prête beaucoup de pouvoir et je
leur remercie c'est vrai que 50
milliards de grands carénages 56
milliards pour 6 EPR dans l'estimation
gouvernementale parce que quand même le
père un coup de 19 milliards mais on va
en faire 6 pour 56 milliards et 64
milliards de dettes c'est aussi un tout
petit peu d'argent donc 3 milliards pour
les tarifs réglementés de vente ça me
paraît tout à fait acceptable
monsieur le ministre
quelques réponses quand même d'abord au
fait que le gouvernement pense aussi il
l'a dit à l'Assemblée nationale que cet
article est un cavalier et qu'il est en
plus il aurait peut-être dû en tout cas
pu être jugé une éligible au titre de
l'article 40 mais il ne s'imise pas dans
les discussions au sein de la commission
des finances ni celle de l'Assemblée
nationale ni celle évidemment du Sénat
pour éventuellement réserver se réserver
le droit de de porter cette controverse
devant le Conseil constitutionnel on
verra
bon monsieur gay vous m'excusez si je
vous réponds pas sur le gaz on passe
déjà pas mal de temps sur l'électricité
aujourd'hui vous aurez quand même
l'occasion de discuter dans le cadre de
la programmation pluralienne de
l'énergie de toutes ces discussions
importantes sur la manière dont on doit
envisager la fourniture d'électricité de
gaz et plus généralement d'énergie en
France pour les années qui viennent et
vous l'aurez en temps voulu
juste quelques chiffres qui vont me
permettre j'espère à
ça a limité à 15 % la hausse des prix au
lieu de 120% sur deux ans le coût pour
les finances publiques c'est 30
milliards en 2022 et 45 en 2023 y
compris les collectivités territoriales
dont vous parliez le cap à 280 euros le
mégawatt ça c'est important monsieur
rapporteur général vous ne lisiez
qu'est-ce qui se passe si on n'est pas
aujourd'hui couvert par le TRV on a
adopté d'ailleurs sur la suggestion d'un
certain nombre d'entre vous un cap à 280
euros le mégawatt pour le prix de
l'électricité pour toutes les TPE qui
vous l'avez dit ont eu la malchance
d'avoir un contrat qui s'interrompait à
l'automne dernier et qui se sont
retrouvés du coup à négocier un peu le
couteau sous la tempe des contrats qui
étaient bien au dessus de ceux qu'ils
avaient auparavant et donc c'est 280
euros l'omégawatt sont intégrés en
moyenne sur tel année dans les factures
qui sont actuellement envoyés par les
fournisseurs d'énergie y compris pour un
certain nombre de boulangers ou d'autres
TPE concernés
on a aussi adopté un amortisseur
électricité pour les PME et pour les
collectivités territoriales alors ça
c'est un peu plus compliqué mais c'est
cohérent avec la réglementation
européenne qui fait comprendre en charge
50% du surcoût au-delà de 180 euros le
mégawatt et ça ça coûte entre 2 et 3
milliards d'euros à la collectivité
nationale et enfin pour les ce qu'on
appelle les énergo intensifs donc les
pour les plus grandes entreprises qui
consomment beaucoup d'énergie un guichet
qui permet aujourd'hui à un certain
nombre d'entreprises de faire valoir la
hausse de leur de leur facture
d'électricité ou de gaz et de demander
des aides qui à ce stade correspondent à
250 millions d'euros attribués depuis
quelques semaines et sans doute une
accélération assez forte puisqu'on voit
l'accélération importante depuis 10
jours avec les factures de 2023 qui
arrivent on a ajouté à votre d'ailleurs
suggestion un filet de sécurité de 430
millions d'euros adoptés à l'été 2022
pour les collectivités dans le cadre de
la loi de financement rectificatif bref
tout ça ça nous coûte beaucoup d'argent
on peut en être fier parce qu'au fond
l'inflation en France est inférieure
ailleurs en Europe et l'entreprise ont
plutôt bien passé la crise contrairement
à nos craintes mais soyons conscient
quand même que tout ça nous coûte
beaucoup d'argent merci est-ce que on
pourrait dire que sur ces trois
amendements
sur l'amendement 14 de Monsieur gay
voilà et que donc ils ne sont pas
adoptés sur l'article 3 bis il n'y a pas
de demande de scrutin public donc qui
est pour
voter l'article avant que je vous passe
la parole pour le 15
là on a fait
on a fait le 16 le 13 et le 12
on a fait le 16 de 13 et le 12
qu'on a on a décidé qu'ils avaient
et maintenant votre article 3 bis voilà
qui est pour l'article 3 bis
qui est contre
qui s'abstient
et n'est pas adopté
d'un public sur le 3 bis je recommence
qui est pour
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 qui est contre
il n'est pas adopté
d'accord
on passe à l'amendement 15
monsieur l'amendement 15 pardon
merci oui c'est une demande de rapport
je sais que le Sénat n'en est pas fan
sur le coup du bouclier tarifaire bon
vous ne nous répondre nous donner des
premiers chiffres
beaucoup beaucoup d'argent on a du mal à
d'ailleurs à avoir à avoir les chiffres
exacts est-ce que vous pouvez nous
confirmer que ça a coûté 20 milliards en
2022 et 37 milliards prévus en 2023 et
juste pour que les gens comprennent ça
veut dire quoi le bouclier tarifaire ça
veut dire qu'on indemnise enfin l'état
indemnise les acteurs alternatifs en
leur donnant de l'argent public pour
appliquer le bouclier tarifaire par
exemple ce que vous venez de dire sur
les sur les boulangers ils avaient un
contrat à 40 ou 50 euros le
mégawattheure la facture a explosé
compliqué pardon
c'est hyper compliqué parce que ça
bouillonne
vous suscitez des vous susciter du
bouillon monsieur
alors Monsieur Guess
est-ce que les présidents de groupe et
le président de la commission des
finances peuvent cesser de bouillonner
tous les deux voilà
parce que donc sur les sur la faire des
280 euros du mégawattheure qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé un boulanger il avait un
contrat à 40 50 ou 60 euros le
mégawattheure on leur on lui a proposé
des fois des contrats 2000 3000 euros le
mégawattheure donc le ministre de
l'Économie a réuni les énergéticiens et
leur a dit maintenant le contrat ne doit
pas dépasser 280 euros le mégawattheure
sauf que ces énergéticiens déjà y pour
plus de 70% de l'énergie qui vous
revendent il achète au prix de 40 euros
donc il y a que les 30 derniers pour
cent même s'il a acheté imaginons à 900
euros le mégawattheure les 30 derniers
pour cent même à 280 euros il ferait
déjà des bénéfices et ça suffit pas
qu'est-ce que fait le gouvernement il de
l'argent public oh acteurs alternatifs
pour appuyer que ce bouclier tarifaire
pour en quelque sorte l'indemniser
c'est-à-dire que le boulanger comme
n'importe quel commerce comme n'importe
quel chef d'entreprise qu'on importe
quel usager il est racketté deux fois
d'abord par l'augmentation de sa facture
électrique et en même temps en tant que
contribuable parce qu'il participe à
donner de l'argent aux énergéticiens
c'est un pur scandale et l'affaire donc
à côté près de 50 milliards d'euros en
deux ans et il faut le dénoncer je vous
remercie si Monsieur gay qui était David
la commission sur cet amendement
et bien la commission madame la
Présidente mes chers collègues n'est pas
favorable cet amendement et pour une
raison d'ailleurs très simple il s'agit
bien d'une étude d'un rapport que vous
demandez au gouvernement
et bien nous nous souhaitons faire le
rapport par nous-mêmes parce que c'est
l'indépendance du Parlement qui
s'exprime à travers le travail de ces
rapports il se trouve que la commission
des finances et je salue son président a
demandé au Rapporteur spécial Madame
Christine lavardde de préparer un
contrôle budgétaire sur cette affaire
parce que il y a ceux qui perdent et il
y a ceux qui gagnent et on aimerait
savoir comment et combien ceux qui
gagnent apportent en contribution à
l'état vous l'aviez évoquée dans les
débats budgétaires parce qu'ils se
trouvent que si le prix augmente il y a
des entreprises qui touchent et qui
touchent plus que d'habitude sans
nécessairement vous avez raison monsieur
gay avoir dépensé pour autant nous avons
des producteurs qui produisent de
l'énergie renouvelable tant mieux pour
eux c'est bien c'est parfait ça tous les
avantages mais qui ne sont absolument
pas tributaires du prix
de l'énergie fossile et qui empoche
tranquillement car vous savez que alors
je reviens pas sur les démembrements
puis je vais dépasser encore mon temps
mais enfin l'appel
l'appel est prioritaire aux énergies
renouvelables donc ils vendent leur
mégawatts à un prix qui est simplement
délirant et je pense qu'ils doivent en
restituer et c'est la raison pour
laquelle la commission des finances a
confié à Madame l'avare de soins de
d'évoquer ce sujet et de la profondeur
je vous rappelle qu'on a un deuxième
texte intérieur
qu'évidemment dans le cadre de
l'exécution de la loi de finance vous
aurez toute la toute la liberté pour
examiner tout ça et à poser toutes les
questions que vous souhaitez au
gouvernement rappeler aussi au sénateur
gay que sur la reine évidemment celui
qui en bénéficie c'est le consommateur
ultime c'est pas le distributeur qui
prend une marge très encadrée et qui
vend l'électricité au rabais au coût de
production d'EDF et c'est pour que
l'ensemble des consommateurs y compris
industriels j'y tiens puissent
bénéficier des investissements de la
nation depuis 77 ans pour bénéficier en
France d'une électricité décarbonée en
volume et pas cher
merci est-ce qu'on peut être d'accord
pour dire que pour être un peu d'accord
pour dire que cet amendement de Monsieur
gay connaît recueille les mêmes votes
que les précédents amendements de
Monsieur gay
d'accord donc il n'est pas adopté
monsieur le Président Kanner pour un
rappel au règlement
de l'article 44 bis ça rappellera des
souvenirs à certains concernant le droit
d'amendement des parlementaires et les
créateurs en l'occurrence et dans le
cadre de la sincérité des débats je
voulais vous soumettre une modification
de notre vote sur l'article 3 bis donc
il y a une incompréhension et le groupe
socialiste souhaite voter l'article 3
bis dans le cadre du vote précédent je
ne sais pas je suis là il est possible
techniquement
à ce stade de votre mise au point et
comme c'était un vote à main levée donc
c'est pour
la liste de ceux qui sont là
on peut pas voter enfin je
on va peut-être finir bon attendez on
finit on finit les amendements et puis
après on verra on verra
le on verra le problème que nous pose le
présent canner comme on le traite sur le
donc l'amendement monsieur gay n'est pas
adopté on est maintenant à l'amendement
numéro 5 de monsieur Lurel il est
rapidement présenté c'est une demande de
rapport qui a eu la sagesse de la
commission un peu mieux rédigée que ce
qui avait été soumis et qu'on vous
demande d'agréer
quelle est la vie de la Commission
la Commission avait en effet est mis un
avis de sagesse la rédaction nouvelle
bon est un peu particulière parce que
elle pose le principe
l'intérêt de nationaliser ça c'est le
premier volet du rapport et un
simultanément un calendrier les étapes
de mise en œuvre ça veut dire qu'en fait
le jugement est donné avant même que
l'étude soit engagée c'est un peu
contradictoire moi je suis gêné par le
la référence au calendrier aux étapes
parce que ça suppose le problème résolu
et donc
c'est manche moi je suis je suis pas
favorable à cette rédaction et je ne
peux pas parler au nom de la commission
sauf à la réunir monsieur le ministre
comme je suis on est deux
c'est un avis défavorable non pas parce
que nous sommes contre les rapports nous
adorons les produire comme vous le savez
ne ces disposition n'a pas de rapport
avec la nationalisation d'EDF 1 et 2
électricité de Mayotte vous le savez est
un opérateur distinct qui n'a qu'une
participation eDF n'a qu'une
participation minoritaire moins de 25%
l'actionnaire majoritaire étant le
département de Mayotte
très bien
il y a une demande de scrutin
d'expérience
oui merci madame la Présidente le
rapporteur a tout à fait raison cette
nouvelle rédaction est un peu
problématique mais surtout je voudrais
demander aux auteurs de l'amendement
pourquoi ils se sont intéressés à
l'extréter le Mayotte qu'on devient de
le rappeler justement le ministre on est
quand même dans un actionnariat qui est
déjà largement public puisque 50% de
c'est le département de Mayotte mais
pourquoi est-ce que l'électricité de
Mayotte pourquoi vous êtes pas intéressé
à ce moment-là aux entreprises lequel le
distribution enfin accessoirement elles
font sur une partie du territoire
national ce que fait aussi EDF et là
pour vous dire électricité de Strasbourg
et détenu à 88,64% par EDF développement
et environnement et à 11,36% par
d'autres actionnaires qu'allez-vous
faire de
um c'est à Metz qui est détenu à 85% par
la Ville de Metz et à 15% par la Caisse
des Dépôts je vais vous épargner la
liste de toutes les électricités enfin
des entreprises auxquelles de
distribution mais j'avoue que je combats
pourquoi Mayotte arrive là comme ça en
plus avec une nouvelle rédaction qui est
un peu abscons donc on nous avons un
avis favorable
vous en avez des
vous êtes bon c'est pas grave
donc
[Musique]
on va donc considérer que sur
l'amendement numéro 5 même vote que sur
alors on va se coter un public ah non
oui ce que tu as un public sur celui-là
monsieur dur elle voulait prendre la
parole pour une explication de votre
président pourquoi on s'est intéressé à
Mayotte parce que on est dans une zone
non interconnectée deuxièmement c'est
j'allais presque d'une continuité
historique en 1975 le président Valéry
Giscard d'Estaing avec la même structure
du capital à nationaliser la Speed en
Guadeloupe la ma Martinique à la
Réunion et en Guyane aujourd'hui à la
même structure à Mayotte avec des
difficultés on a monopole EDF pour le
transport dans les années donc vous
voyez c'est c'est différent ensuite il y
avait une ambiguïté sur l'application
dtrve dans les outre-mer aujourd'hui
c'est réglé le code de l'énergie est
clair je veux bien admettre que
la nouvelle rédaction précise les
modalités et que
on ne discute pas c'est vrai du principe
de la nationalisation on admet qu'il
faut nationaliser et qui fait un
calendrier voilà
était l'amendement et qui avait reçu un
avis de sagesse
[Musique]
donc il a reçu un double avis
défavorable le scrutin est ouvert
personne ne demande à voter le scrutin
est clos votant 342 exprimé 336% contre
236 le Sénat n'a pas adopté je me vois
l'article 3 terres qui est pour
qui est pour l'article 3 TER
personne
j'en ai un j'envoie un
non parce que
pas sur chaque article faire deux votes
quand même vous voyez donc là essayer de
vous décider dès le premier vote
donc je recommence qui est pour
l'article 3 terres ah bah voilà
il y en a
qui est contre
moi je vais demander
bon alors
1 2 3 4
c'est l'article 3 termes qu'on est en
train de voter
monsieur luret vous faites quoi avec vos
mains
il est adopté
et l'article 4 est supprimé et je vais
suspendre quelques instants la séance
pour régler quelques petites questions
évoquées tout à l'heure par le rappel le
règlement du président kaner
[Musique]
la séance est reprise je donne la parole
au président rénal
la Présidente je vous demande une minute
de suspension pour que la Commission se
réunisse pour étudier un amendement de
rétablissement et ensuite pouvoir faire
une deuxième délibération de l'article 3
bis en application d'un 43 lignée à 4 du
règlement mais tout d'abord une minute
de suspension pour que la Commission se
réunisse et me mandat officiellement la
séance est suspendue pour une minute
la première année je me suis pété 3 fois
la gueule je me suis ouvert la mettre au
calme etc
d'abord la séance est reprise et en
application de l'article 43
je vous la donne d'abord président
e c'est juste pour vous donner le
résultat de la commission donc
la commission donc demande à la
Commission des finances demande donc une
deuxième délibération sur l'article 3
vis en application d'Artic 43
l'inéa 4 du Règlement madame la
Présidente merci donc quelle est la vie
du gouvernement sur cette demande de
délibération
ah d'accord donc la vie est plutôt
défavorable la première délibération lui
semblait en fait plutôt pas mal
d'accord
donc que on va devoir consulter le Sénat
sur la deuxième délibération monsieur
Capu vous voulez vous exprimer vous êtes
contre
c'est juste que si vous êtes contre si
vous n'êtes pas contre vous n'avez pas
la parole il n'y a pas d'explication de
votre est-ce que vous êtes contre je
suis contre vous êtes contre la deuxième
délibération ok les ID dans ce cas vous
faites le contre exactement je fais
l'opposition contre il me semblait comme
la rappeler le ministre que
les auteurs de la proposition s'était
rendu compte que c'était à la fois un
cavalier que cet article 3 était un
cavalier et qu'il était il recevable
c'est la raison pour laquelle le
président de la commission des finances
s'était rendu compte et avait voté
contre n'avait pas voté cet article 3
bis ça me paraissait tout à fait logique
donc cette seconde délibération me
paraît totalement inopportune je dirais
même que c'est presque un passage en
force madame la Présidente pour
reprendre des arguments que nous avons
eu par le passé si José mais je n'irai
pas jusque là donc il me semble en
revanche que sur le fond de cette
seconde délibération elle elle ne
s'impose d'autant pas d'autant moins que
j'ai bien compris que la réécriture de
l'article 3 bis par le rapporteur
Gérard Longuet et meilleur effectivement
que l'écriture première de l'amende de
l'article de telle sorte qui est
peut-être ça qui a un petit peu induit
en erreur nos collègues des rang de la
gauche il n'en reste pas moins que sur
l'argument développé par le rapporteur
sur le fait que on décale on supprime
l'effet de seuil en réalité on ne
supprime pas l'effet on ne fait que le
décaler on ne fait que le décaler des
autres des TPE en dessous de 36 kVA au
PME et l'effet de seuil existera
toujours on le décale uniquement
au plus grosses entreprises mais il y
aura toujours un effet de seuil sur cet
article 3 bis on est bien dans le sujet
c'est la raison pour laquelle
madame le Président il me semble
effectivement
que cette seconde délibération n'est pas
opportune
bien je vous remercie
anecdotique mais je suis Madame la
Présidente Monsieur Capu et
bien entendu que vous étiez contre mais
c'est en application de l'article 43
alinéa 4 que cette seconde délibération
va être soumise au vote du Sénat c'est
donc qu'on forme au règlement donc qui
est pour cette seconde délibération
qui est contre qui s'abstient la seconde
délibération était donc décidé
conformément à l'article 43 alinéa 5
monsieur Capu lorsqu'il y a dû à une
seconde délibération les textes adoptées
lors de la première délibération sera
envoyé à la commission qui doit
présenter un nouveau rapport la
Commission a déposé un amendement de
rétablissement de l'article 3 bis que
vous avez que nous avons là que je vous
tout le monde là
je vous lirai déjà ainsi cet article où
il arrive
tu le rapporteur va vous le présenter
monsieur rapporteur vous pouvez le
présenter en un mot enfin
favorable à revenir au texte de la
commission quelle est la vie du
gouvernement
tout à l'heure que j'ai longuement
exprimé des favorables d'accord
maison qui est pour qui est contre qui
s'abstient il est adopté et lorsque
c'est un nouveau 3B il n'y a pas lieu de
plus lieu de voter sur l'article 3 bis
il le réécrit je vais mettre au voie
maintenant l'ensemble de la proposition
de loi pour lequel je suis saisie pour
laquelle je suis saisie d'un demande de
ce que tu as publié par le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicain
le scrutin est ouvert
et poser un truc important non non parce
que j'ai vu
messieurs les huissiers on ouvre le
scrutin est ouvert
plus personne ne demande à voter le
scrutin est donc clos
vote en 343 exprimé 329 pour 206 contre
123 le Sénat a adopté
et nous allons maintenant
poursuivre l'ordre du jour avec la
discussion de la proposition de loi
constitutionnelle
j'ai
ce 30 secondes
pour la rotation des équipages
pardonnez-moi mais il faut laisser
s'installer
la commission des lois